Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Pritler und ich sag hallo alle da draußen an den Hörgeräten.
Es ist wieder Corona Time. Corona Weekly und natürlich gibt's dazu auch den Pavel Hallupavel.
Ja, jetzt haben wir ja da vor zwei Wochen angefangen, so langsam mal den Sommer aufzufegen und versucht so ein bisschen überhaupt erstmal uns einzunorden. Ich glaube, es war auch erstmal erforderlich.
Überhaupt selber erstmal wieder diesen Kopf, um diese ganze Thematik ähm herumgeschlungen zu bekommen. Ich habe richtig gemerkt, wie ich so.
Rausgefallen bin, aber wahrscheinlich auch, weil ich's wollte, weil oder was einfach erforderlich war, ne? So so ein bisschen.
Abstand zu gewinnen und nochmal so den Kopf frei zu spülen und irgendwie mal über was anderes nachzudenken als permanente Krisen, weil war ja klar, dass jetzt hier im Herbst und im Winter.
Noch so einiges auf uns zukommt, nicht nur in Bezug auf Corona, sondern auch sowas das sonstige Welt geschehen betrifft.
Ja, ja, ich konnte jetzt nicht so ganz völlig Abstand äh gewinnen, weil ich halt schon jeden Tag meine Corona-Liste
musste, so das ist immer ein bisschen mit ja Handarbeit,
verbunden und äh sodass ich schon jeden Tag eigentlich mal immer dann nach dem aktualisierenden Blick auf die Zahlen.
Geworfen habe.
Aber diesen Effekt gibt's schon, ne, hast du ja letztes Mal schon gesagt, du warst immer dran und dann hast du äh auch weiterhin äh dran gearbeitet und du kommst auch ein bisschen voran, was so deine anstehenden Visualisierungen betrifft, et cetera. Gibt's denn da äh äh Neues, was dein.
Apparat so.
Ganz ganz langsam, ich hab hier und da mal so nämlich 'ne Stunde rangesetzt und hab halt jetzt so ja.
Die Basis ein bisschen weiterentwickelt und äh berechne mir jetzt
Zahlen, so die täglichen Fallzahlen für Deutschland und die
Bundesländer oder für Berlin und äh auch für die einzelnen Landkreise jetzt die Zeit rein ähm so aus den ähm RKI Grunddaten, aus den veröffentlichten
und ähm was noch fehlt ist sozusagen jetzt eine neue Visualisierungsteil und ein neuer Darstellungsteil, der halt auf dieser
etwas neuen äh Datenbasis arbeitet, aber
Schauen wir mal. Ich meine, was halt im Sommer auch so ein bisschen oder was halt ein bisschen Ruhe reingebracht hat, dass sich halt aber auch über mehrere Wochen nicht allzu viel getan hat
bei den Zahlen letztlich war äh der gesamte Juli,
nicht so besonders aufregend. Ich meine, es hat da zwar,
ging dann die Zahlen langsam hoch, aber das war's dann, die letzte Aufregung war eigentlich im im Juni und dann eben jetzt
dann im im August so insofern ja, war tatsächlich eine gewisse Ruhepause da und war dann auch unklar,
wie interessant wird denn das Thema noch ähm das Thema zahlen.
Ja, dann fangen wir doch mit den Zahlen mal äh an. Machen wir ja eigentlich immer ganz,
traditionell für die Leute, die vielleicht das erste Mal einschalten oder schon wieder alles vergessen haben. Du ähm.
Hol's dir die Daten direkt vom RKI. Ähm,
Da war ja jetzt sozusagen auch äh immer die Frage, äh haben wir denn überhaupt alle Daten, die äh die es jemals äh gab, da hast du ja einiges nachgeholt und wenn ich das richtig sehe
bis jetzt so mehr oder weniger vollständig. Also seit es Daten gibt, hast du so gut wie alle. Richtig?
Ja, bis auf irgendwie zwei Tage, die bisher noch äh fehlen, nämlich der fünfundzwanzigste Dritte und der sechsundzwanzigste Dritte, da.
Äh
also der dreiundzwanzigste scheint der erste Tag, also der dreiundzwanzigste dritte war wohl der erste Tag an dem diese Daten äh zum Herunterladen angeboten
wurden so in der Form, sagt hundertprozentig weiß ich's nicht, aber der Punkt ist in dem Datensatz von dreiundzwanzigsten dritten
fehlt halt noch das Fleck, wie viel jetzt an neuen und wie viel an alten Fällen es gegeben hat, das fängt erst am vierundzwanzigsten drit.
Fällt neuer Fall,
So, deswegen vermute ich, sozusagen dreiundzwanzigste dritte, so der erste Dampf war, äh, weil ohne dieses Feld neuer Fall kann man halt,
auch nicht die Zahlen dann berechnen, so. Ich meine gut, die Daten gab's beim RKI vorher auch schon, aber ich vermute mal, die wurden vorher nicht in der Form ausgespielt oder.
Äh zur Verfügung gestellt. Das ist jedenfalls meine These und ohne dieses Feld neuer Fall nützen eigentlich auch.
Die Daten von den Vortagen nicht, weil man dann die offiziellen Zahlen rein ohne dieses Feld nicht rekonstruieren kann.
Okay,
so das ganze fließt in deine Tabelle, in deine Risiko äh Tabelle auf deiner Webseite, den Link haben wir natürlich auch nochmal bei uns in den äh Shownotes und dort ist halt alles schön nach Bundesländern aufgelistet, leider derzeit noch immer.
Ähm quasi also was heißt leider, also was man den aktuellen Tag sozusagen.
Rückblick auf die letzten vierzehn Tage, also genau genommen äh immer ein Blick auf die letzten sieben Tage und auf,
die sieben Tage davor, um daraus eben ein Bild zu generieren, wie es denn gerade so läuft.
Und glaub dein Wunsch auch und mein Wunsch auch und der Wunsch auch wieder andere war sozusagen diese Verläufe auch mal ein bisschen besser visualisiert zu bekommen. Da bist du jetzt aber.
In Vorbereitung, richtig?
Ja, also ich habe jetzt keinen genauen Zeitplan, sondern ich mache da halt immer ein bisschen was, wenn äh ja, wenn ich mich motiviert fühle und ein bisschen Zeit habe, so.
Okay. Wir sind gespannt,
Dann schauen wir doch mal, was jetzt äh die Situation in Deutschland derzeit so ist. Wie hat sich das in den letzten zwei Wochen entwickelt? Wir hatten ja jetzt diese tja, ich würde mal sagen, dritte Welle eigentlich, ne? Wenn man jetzt mal,
Deutschland anschaut, wir hatten halt den großen Ausbruch am Anfang, Lokdown und so weiter. Dann war äh erstmal ein bisschen Ruhe, dann gab's halt diese ganzen Tönis
Ausbrüche, also in der Fleischindustrie, nicht nur bei Tönnies auf Wiesenhof und so weiter, also äh spezifische Problematiken.
In bestimmten Industriebereichen gekoppelt mit äh.
Plus Erntehelfer plus so Altenheime plus andere Dinge, die haben
offenbar für einen, dann für einen Zwischenpeak äh halt im Juni gesagt, so das war dann, ich sage mal, im Prinzip die zweite Welle, die
in Berlin ein bisschen ausgeprägter war, als in Deutschland, die aber deutlich auf jeden Fall sichtbar ist. Da haben sich halt innerhalb von einer Woche plötzlich hat sich der sieben Tagesdurchschnitt verdoppelt.
So, hat dann aber nicht sehr lange angehalten, so, das ging halt dann so zehn Tage ungefähr gingen die Zahlen hoch,
dann wieder ja runter zu gehen und fast,
dass absolute Tief zu erreichen, um dann in den letzten acht Wochen äh dann wieder anzusteigen. So äh bis,
etwa Samstag. Ähm, wer weiß.
Heute haben wir äh wir.
Helfen diese anti-Corona-Dämmen.
Ja, warte mal, wir müssen mal, ich habe ja wieder vergessen, das Datum zu sagen. Also heute, jetzt nehmen wir auf am dritten September, äh, Donnerstag, dritter September und ähm ja, Samstag war, als hier in Berlin wieder die Schwobler äh durch die Gegend zogen.
Genau und äh seitdem aber ähm gehen die Zahlen runter. Äh natürlich gibt's da keinen Zusammenhang, weil äh so die.
Ja, da immer eine gewisse Zeitverzögerung drin ist, aber aus irgen.
Dass die zum Rückgang jetzt.
Nein, nein.
Haben.
Ja, das wäre ein schöner Witz so nach dem Motto, das Virus hat sich denn jetzt so ein Angst gekriegt.
Weggeschrien worden.
Und so, genau, ist weggeschrien worden, genauso wird's ganz bestimmt gewesen sein. Nein, jedenfalls,
ungefähr ja seit seit fast einer Woche, also fünf, sechs Tagen,
geht der sieben Tage Durchschnitt definitiv zurück nicht sehr stark. So also wir sind,
immer noch absolut auf einem Wert, der zuletzt im April äh,
so hoch war, aber äh bundesweit jetzt äh ist.
R knapp unter eins und ja, der sieben Tage Schnitt sinkt langsam. Und wenn man jetzt einen Blick.
Die Testzahlen wirft, die man ja immer so mit betrachten muss. Kann man sehen, dass die Tests
in der vergangenen Woche in Kalenderwoche fünfunddreißig
auch noch weiter angestiegen sind auf jetzt eins Komma eins Millionen Tests, die in dieser Woche gemacht worden sind
mit einer positiven Quote von null Komma sieben vier Prozent. Die positiven Quotes, also auch gesunken
so vom in der Vorwoche null Komma acht fünf und davor in den zwei Wochen gab's also auch einen Anstieg in den
KW zweiunddreißig war sie dann am höchsten bei ein Prozent
ist seitdem äh gesunken. Während sie irgendwann mal in der KW siebenzwanzig äh hal.
Quasi am niedrigsten irgendeine LKW achtundzwanzig sogar bei null Komma fünf neun Prozent positiven Quote
so.
Sollten wir vielleicht auch nochmal kurz sagen, warum das wichtig ist, also wenn viel getestet wird, aber man hat sehr wenig positive Fälle, dann spricht das eben auch für eine relativ niedrige dunkelziffer sozusagen, also dann dann passt das sozusagen.
Ihr ja, also es ist ja zum einen.
Genauer ist die Aussage äh oder kann man zumindest annehmen, dass es so ist. Also in USA zum Beispiel liegt diese Quote glaube ich auch immer noch relativ
immer noch einen relativ schlechten Wert, das heißt es wird zwar getestet und man findet Fälle, aber man findet eben so viele Fälle beim Testen
Also der Anteil im Vergleich zu den negativen Test äh der also der Anteil der positiven Testvergleich zu den negativen Testen ist so hoch, dass man einfach das Gefühl hat, okay, wenn wir jetzt,
doppelt so viel testen würden, dann würden wir auch nochmal extrem viel mehr Fälle finden, ne, während das in Deutschland, wenn wir jetzt doppelt so viel testen würden, würden wir zwar auch nochmal ein paar finden, aber hal,
nicht ansatzweise so viel.
Definitiv. Äh also der der also der Punkt ist, genau, dass man ähm sagen immer, wenn man einen Blick,
nur auf die Zahlen wirft ohne die Testzahlen in Betracht zu ziehen, ist es eben so, dass 'ne jede Veränderung des Testregimes die Zahlen nach oben oder nach unten äh bewegen
kann und wenn man das jetzt nicht mit im Auge hat so dann können die reinen Zahlen täuschen, aber was man halt.
Aufgrund dessen, dass die Zahl der Tests jetzt ausgeweitet wurde in der letzten Woche, aber die Zahl der positiv getesteten.
Absolut zurückgegangen ist, also von achttausendneunhundert auf achttausendeinhundertachtundsiebzig.
So von der Vorwoche zu der letzten Vorvorwoche, zu der letzten Woche ähm so mehr Tests
weniger positiv getestete, heißt, dass man tatsächlich davon ausgehen kann, dass die Zahl der Fälle
rückläufig ist und nicht etwa dadurch äh ähm komm
dass jetzt weniger Tests gemacht werden. Das kann ja auch, wenn ich jetzt plötzlich, wenn uns jetzt die Testmaterialien ausgehen würden und nur noch die Hälfte der Tests gemacht wird, würden die Zahlen auch runtergehen
so, aber ähm ja, das ist halt nicht der Fall, das heißt können sagen bei,
allen vorbehalten, eben bei allen Verzerrungen der Zahlen durch alle möglichen Effe,
können wir aber sagen, dass es mit an Sicherheit grenzende Wahrscheinlichkeit
die äh Fälle äh tatsächlich zurückgegangen äh sind, also tatsächlich auch die Infektion gerade leicht rückläufig sind.
Ja was äh eine gute Sache ist. Jedenfalls auf äh äh Deutschland bezogen, jetzt deutschlandweit betrachtet.
Ja, wenn man sich die Landkreise anschaut, sieht's natürlich wieder etwas differenzierter aus.
Also erstmal bei den Bundesländern kann man auch sagen bei den Bundesländern geht's mittlerweile auch,
zehn Ländern von sechzehn Bundesländern äh sind auch die Zahlen rückläufig so nur ja in Bremen geht's geht's gerade noch hoch,
Berlin ist wieder leicht angestiegen. Hamburg steigt an,
tatsächlich hat den höchsten Anstieg zu vermelden. Jetzt hat sich fast ja hat sich's mehr als verdoppelt äh tatsächlich äh in den letzten sieben Tagen gegenüber den sieben Tagen davor.
Ja Thüringen auch leicht erhöht von einundsechzig auf achtundsechzig.
Gestiegen, aber sagt in den meisten Ländern vor allem äh halt in.
Bayern und Baden-Württemberg die sehr stark betroffen waren jetzt bei dem Anstieg auch in den in der letzten Woche. Da hat's auch den Piek jetzt offenbar überschritten. So.
Ja, da sind auch die Zahlen leicht rückläufig. Er hängt noch auf einem relativ hohen Niveau allerdings. Soll auch sagen, dass nirgendwo äh die Zahl, also,
höchste Wert im Moment äh ist in Baden-Württemberg mit fünfzehn Neuerkranken äh auf hunderttausend in den letzten sieben Tagen,
und ja, das ist jetzt nicht schön, ist aber jetzt auch nicht super alarmierend und ist halt von dem offiziellen Wert fünfzig oder gar hundert, der äh,
wird's glaube ich auf den Kanaren oder so äh gesetzt wurde von den Spaniern als Limit, wo sie dann wieder neue Logdown ausrufen wollen, wenn der überschritten ist, äh sind wir halt in Deutschland im Moment noch weit entfernt
Also in den Top dreißig haben wir halt,
fünfzehn Mal Bayern vertreten. Im Moment wurde wohl beide Spitzenreiter aus Rheinland-Pfalz kommt gerade Landkreis Trier-Saarburg, ich hab gar nicht geguckt, was da jetzt genau los ist. Ja, da gab's,
den Ausbruch dann von zehn auf dreiundsechzig.
Fälle angestiegen, ist jetzt auch nicht so super Ding, aber ist ein relativ kleiner Landkreis mit hundertfünfzigtausend Einwohnern knapp da,
wirkt sich das schon ganz gut aus.
Ja, also man merkt auf jeden Fall, dass Virus steckt vor allem in Bayern und in Baden-Württemberg drin. So und,
auch gleich nochmal was zu sagen äh äh nochmal auf den aktuellen Drosten-Podcast vielleicht kurz zu sprechen kommen, aber das das ist ja jetzt seit längerer Zeit schon
der Fall auch Bad auch Nordrhein-Westfalen spielt da so ein bisschen mit, also im Wesentlichen ist diese Nord-Süd.
Verteilung in Deutschland einfach äh nach wie vor deutlich an den Zahlen abzulesen.
Wobei, wie gesagt, Berlin mischt halt auch immer wieder oben um und interessanterweise Hamburg und Bremen hüpfen dann auch immer mal wieder so nach oben und sinken dann wieder, also.
Ja, ich denke, das ist halt einfach dann ein so ein Metropoleneffekt auch, ne. Also du hast halt einfach sehr viel mehr.
Reisetätigkeit, Aktivität, es wird einfach mehr in die Städte
reingetragen und hier aus den Stritten wieder Städten wieder rausgetragen. Da trifft man sich halt dann doch eher
während's halt in den äh anderen Landkreisen so in etwas weniger bevölkerten Mecklenburg-Vorpommern et cetera, da hast du das eben nicht und deswegen hält sich das da eben auch dauerhaft niedrig.
Ich meine Berlin hat ja jetzt 'ne Liste auch veröffentlicht zu 'ner Auswertung.
Ähm das Gesundheitsamtes oder der Gesundheitsämter, wo sich die Leute eigentlich infizieren, etwas, was wir ja ganz, ganz.
Lange auch äh sagen, nachgefragt haben, so, wo kommt es denn zu Infektionen? Und nach dieser Liste,
haben wohl ungefähr die Hälfte aller Ansteckungen finden im privaten Bereich statt, so im privaten Haushalt, was dort stand.
Natürlich so ein bisschen die Frage allerdings offen lässt
äh so okay, wie sind denn dann jetzt die Ansteckungen eigentlich in die Familien hineingekommen? Könnte man sagen, okay, das waren vielleicht genau die andere Hälfte äh der Ansteckung, die aber dann
komplett verteilt sind über ich weiß nicht zwanzig oder dreißig verschiedene.
Ja Anlässe oder oder Orte und
Da fällt jetzt groß nichts äh äh tatsächlich raus und Kirchen waren gar nicht erwähnt in,
sondern nur Vereine und ähnliches. Ich weiß nicht, ob die die Kirchen da mit dabei gepackt haben, aber ähm,
ja also das ist wohl die Situation und äh insofern war vielleicht wenn man
zahlen jetzt Ärzte und sagen auch im besonders im privaten Bereich eben auch aufpassen, wenn man den Leute besucht oder Grillpartys oder so macht, äh sollte man dann
trotzdem auch auf Abstand halten, nicht verzichten.
Genau, Grillpartys auch weiterhin nur im Freien. Auch aus anderen generellen Sicherheitserwä.
Ja, ja. Aber dann auch äh trotzdem halt äh aufpassen so ähm ja, sagt Abstand halten.
Die Todesrate ist natürlich auch interessant, ne?
Ja, das äh wurde auch in den letzten Wochen dann, ich meine, wir haben auch schon mal drüber gesprochen, dass äh wir ja gesagt haben, ja, hm, die
Zahl der Toten korrespondiert jetzt nicht wirklich mit den Anstiegen bei den Fallzahlen oder oder.
Die Zahlen sind überhaupt sowieso schon sehr klein. In Berlin ist jetzt seit.
Über einer Woche äh niemand mehr verstorben.
Und äh auch bundesweit sind die Zahlen unauffällig. So, äh wenn man sagen, okay, da passiert eigentlich nichts und Gründe dafür.
Äh sind vielfältig, hatten wir auch schon äh gesagt, so eine eine Sache ist die Ausweitung,
des Tests Regimes, die zu übertrieben hohen,
geführt hat, obwohl der Anstieg real war, selber nicht nur durch jetzt die Ausweitung der Tests, sondern aber wirklich ein aber der sah halt stärker aus als.
Er wirklich war, dann ist es wohl so, dass es jetzt deutlich mehr.
Jüngere Leute getroffen hat bei den Ansteckungen als Ältere, was sich dann natürlich auch auf die Sterbe äh Zahlen auswirkt und dann wird jetzt auch immer wieder heiß diskutiert, ob das Virus jetzt weniger,
aggressiv oder weniger tödlich geworden ist durch gewisse Mutationen. Das ist noch umstritten.
Dass tatsächlich so ist, also.
Irgendwie genetische Nachweise ähm gibt es da jetzt nicht, also.
Mutation, aber gibt keinen Nachweis, dass sie irgendwie weniger tödlich äh sein,
soll.
Also man kann da geht schon davon aus, dass so etwas so etwas auslösen kann, bloß nicht unbedingt in so kurzem Zeitraum. Also das, das, das müsste eigentlich ein Effekt sein, der sich eben über einen längeren Zeitraum entwickelt und.
Ja beziehungsweise ich meine durch Zufall, ich meine Mutationen sind halt Zufall, das könnte natürlich jederzeit,
passieren auch, dass solche Mutationen,
muss man halt natürlich auch nachweisen beziehungsweise auch im Genom irgendwo was was finden, was hat sich da verändert und dann auch anhand der Zahlen dann sehen im Vergleich, ob
denn da wo sich diese Art von Virus ausbreitet, ist grundsätzlich weniger Todesfälle oder weniger schwere Verläufe gibt und,
Dafür gibt es wohl noch keinen Anhaltspunkt. Ähm das heißt, inwiewieweit das ein Faktor ist, ist halt nicht so ganz klar,
möglich, wär's trotzdem und dann nicht zule.
Könnte es auch sein, dass äh einfach mehr Erfahrung bei der Behandlung äh jetzt
da ist, weil man besser versteht wie und wo das Virus eigentlich angreift.
Ja im Übrigen, das sollte man jetzt auch nicht unerwähnt lassen äh Christian Drosten ist back. Es ist jetzt also tatsächlich eine neue Ausgabe des äh Corona Virus.
Update-Podcast rausgekommen, wo er denn dann auch mal selber wieder dabei ist. Es gab ja verschiedene Ausgaben zu verschiedenen Wissenschaftsrunden, auch alles nicht ganz äh uninteressant. Aber natürlich Deutschland.
Natürlich an der Nadel und war schon die ganze Zeit jetzt äh völlig ähm unterversorgt über den Sommer.
Weil wir brauchen ja unseren unseren Drosten-Podcast von
täglicher Erscheinung sogar weit entfernt. Ich glaube der Modus ist jetzt, dass er alle zwei Wochen äh reinkommt, sich abwechselt mit einer anderen äh Kollegin in etwas andere äh Expertise hatten dann nochmal eine andere
Perspektive öffnen soll, das muss man schauen, das werden wir dann nächstes äh nächste Woche wahrscheinlich sehen. Ich muss jetzt sagen, du hast hier nicht nicht gehört, ne, die neue.
Ja ich hab sie vermutlich gehört, also ich hab's Anfang Anfang gehört, ich hab auch das Ende gehört, ich hab auch dazwischen 'ne ganze Menge gehört, aber ich bin glaub ich zwischendurch eingeschlafen, das hab ich dann irgendwie irgendwann hab ich nicht mehr so richt,
macht die Sätze, wie diesmal so richtig äh äh Sinn, kommt davon, wenn man das sozusagen als letztes am Tag äh macht und dann nochmal so ein Podcast ein Bild hört. Aber ich glaube, so ein,
Bisschen sein äh Spinn rausgehört zu haben. Er hat sich nämlich äh viel an einem Paper abgearbeitet.
Ähm was ich so äh bisschen mit dieser Perkulationstheorie äh beschäftigt hatten. Das war so ein bisschen seine These.
Was jetzt äh eben auch reinspielt in diese Frage mit heißen diese Zahlen jetzt, dass es gut wird, ja? Oder oder.
Kann es sich jederzeit ändern und warum ändert es sich in Deutschland nicht, während wir jetzt in Spanien, Frankreich,
wieder massive Ausbruchs äh Szenarien haben. Ja, also Spanien liegt derzeit vor den USA, was so ähm
die Neuinfektion im
es zur Bevölkerung betrifft und Frankreich ist noch nicht ganz da, wo die USA ist, aber auch da passiert gerade eben sehr viel
Und man kann sich natürlich fragen, so ja okay, warum bei uns nicht so äh nicht Reisetätigkeit, ladala, also wir sind ja jetzt auch nicht so weit auseinander, man fragt sich eben, was ist sozusagen der Grund dafür.
Und ja er hat dann eben so ein Pepper äh zitiert und dann sehr ausführlich, also der Podcast ist ja auch relativ lang, sehr ausführlich dieses Prinzip der Perkulation äh.
Erläutert und muss sagen, ich habe, glaube ich, in in keinem.
Podcast der letzten Zeit so viele neue Fachbegriffe gelernt, so Begriffe, die ich nur überhaupt noch nicht auf der Kette hatte ähm wie mit Christian Drosten, Pakulation ist wiederum so ein weiteres Wort. Kennst du das Wort? Sagt dir das was.
Nein, nein.
Also es heißt äh wörtlich eigentlich durch Sickerung.
Und worauf es anspielt ist so eine Theorie, die eben sagt, dass man zwar.
Eine gewisse Verbreitung von etwas haben kann, aber dass es eben erst dann alles schlimm wird oder dann erst alles in Bewegung kommt, wenn ein gewisser Schwellwert überschritten wird.
Einfaches Beispiel mit dem er eingestiegen ist, ist so, du kannst halt irgendwie Wasser in so einen Kaffeefilter äh tropfen lassen, der voll mit Kaffee äh gefüllt ist, aber da kommt halt unten nichts raus. Warum? Na ja
Weil eben dieses Material, dieses Wasser, was da reinkommt, in so einem trockenen Zustand erstmal langsam aufnimmt. Und erst wenn eben diese Durchsickerung.
Punkt erreicht hat, wo du mehr oder weniger von oben bis unten so eine durchgehende Wasserkette hast.
Dann führt ein Tropfen oben rein dazu, dass er auch unten wieder rauströpft. Und dann hast du quasi erstmal so einen Effekt oder ähnliche Modelle mit.
Kugeln und Metallkugeln und umso mehr Metallkugeln und so 'ne Mischung hast, umso mehr steigt dann die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass da eben auch ein Strom durchgehen kann, der halt durch die Holzkugel erstmal verhindert wird, aber eben, wenn du so ein, so eine,
entsprechende Mindestmenge Ahas, dann dann beginnt das ganze System sich auf einmal zu bewegen und dann tut es auf einmal etwas.
Was es vorher überhaupt nicht getan hat. Du hast halt sozusagen nichts gesehen und das ist so ein bisschen sein Bild für den Zustand, der Pandemie.
Und sagt eben auch, dass wir Fimmen, also dass das alles immer so mit mit Fragezeichen natürlich, ne? Alles.
Erstmal so Ideen, aber das ist ein interessantes Bild, dass die Tatsache, dass wir in Deutschland eben so früh reagiert haben. Ja, wir haben ja.
Anders als Spanien, Frankreich und so weiter, also die meisten Länder in den äh in Europa und überhaupt auch weltweit haben ja quasi die Pandemie daran erkannt, dass sie viele Fälle hatten.
Ja, da waren dann auf einmal viele Leute krank. Und wir wissen ja mittlerweile, wenn jemand krank ist, dann ist sozusagen schon mal sehr viel mehr Zeit vergangen.
Da ist jemand, ne? Hat sich den Virus äh reingeholt und dann hatte die Krankheit Zeit und,
Dann musstest du auch noch abwarten bis viele Leute das hatten und dann fällt dir auf einmal auf so okay alle husten, äh Leute sterben, WhatsApp, wir müssen nachher irgendwie mal reagieren. Während eben in Deutschland durch dieses Hintergrund äh Testing.
Also das quasi schon im Februar auf das äh Kopf zwei Virus mitgetestet wurde in so einem normalen Durchlauf beim Testen auf andere.
Viren, ne? Also diese ganz normale äh Grippescreening et cetera, was halt am laufenden Meter irgendwie stattfindet, da haben sie halt einfach mal mitgetestet und dann haben sie halt eben,
Schon so die ersten Intruder festgestellt und die erste weitergereichte Infektion und deswegen hatten wir da so einen Zeitvorsprung und dann der relativ frühe Lokdown
Also relativ im Vergleich eben zu anderen Ländern.
Kann eben jetzt dazu geführt haben, also ich meine, wir hatten ja in Spanien und Frankreich und so weiter. Die hatten ja alle schlimmere Ausbrüche und das bedeutet aber auch, dass quasi das Land jetzt eben auch sehr viel mehr angesickert ist.
Und wenn jetzt eben.
Wieder neue Fälle dazukommen, durch Reisetätigkeit, durch Nachlässigkeit, durch die Rücknahme von Maßnahmen et cetera oder zu wenig Masken oder was auch immer dann der Auslöser ist
dass dann eben dieser diese Gesamtpopulation,
schon so weit durchgefeuchtet ist, dass es dann eben auch nicht so viel braucht, bis es dann wieder anfängt zu tropfen.
Ähm und na ja.
Da bin ich dann, glaube ich, auch irgendwann eingeschlafen. Ich kann jetzt nicht mehr genau sagen, was jetzt die Schlussfolgerung daraus war, ich werde mir das nochmal anhören. Fand das aber auf jeden Fall mal eine ganz interessanten Ansatz, äh wie man drüber nachdenken kann, weil das eben dann auch so ein bisschen
eine Erklärung sein kann mit A, warum hatten wir jetzt eben noch keine starke Welle oder kommt sie vielleicht noch? Und die Antwort ist
kann sein, dass sie kommt oder auch nicht
Wissen wir nicht, weil es halt jetzt für diesen Schwellwert gibt's keine keine klare Quantifizierung, aber man kann da jetzt nicht eine Zahl dran kleben, weil das hängt eben davon ab
Wie ist deine Gesellschaft organisiert, wie was was wie getrennt sind deine deine Gruppen voneinander, ne? Und das also,
umso umso getrennter eben die Cluster voneinander sind, also umso mehr die gesellschaftlichen Gruppen voneinander getrennt sind, umso
resistenter kann so eine Population sein und dann hast du halt in anderen Ländern, hast du einfach einen anderen Modus
größere Familienverbünde, mehr Familien, Feste, was weiß ich und die seit Jahren so beklagte Isolation in Deutschland, so dass alle irgendwie so alleine wohnen und irgendwie,
Kontakt mehr haben, könnte sich dann auch noch als ganz praktisch in so einer Pandemie äh herausstellen.
Also das war jetzt so ein bisschen das, was ich äh davon äh im ersten Ansatz mitgenommen habe, Forschung.
Findet auf jeden Fall äh statt und er ist wohl ganz fleißig dabei. Ja, Grundlagenforschung voranzutreiben.
Also ja, das passt so ein bisschen auch zu der Beobachtung, die ich gemacht habe, dass wenn's irgendwo.
Hoch kocht. Ähm selbst wenn's nur so ein paar Cluster sind, so ist es oft so, dass dass es dann doch nicht wirklich zur Ruhe.
Kommt dann, das ist halt echt,
länger dauert und so Baden-Württemberg und Bayern beispielsweise, die ja auch wie speziell Bayern halt sehr stark betroffen war, hat halt immer noch die Hälfte der Landkreise in den top.
Dreißig so und kommt einfach nicht zur Ruhe so richtig.
Weil die schon so angesickert sind, ne? Das heißt immer wenn wieder Druck ist, dann dann wird sich's dort sehr viel schneller auswirken, als jetzt zum Beispiel in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Das, also das liegt dieses Bild zumindest erstmal nahe und sobald man eben die Zahlen jetzt,
sich anschauen kann.
Passt, passt das zumindest zu so einem, zu so einem Bild, ne? Also man kann jetzt nicht davon ausgehen, zum Beispiel, um das mal umzudrehen, dass wir jetzt in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern auf einmal ein langer, anhaltenden, starken Ausbruch haben werden.
Es kann natürlich trotzdem passieren, aber es ist Anleitlich, es ist irgendwie ähm ein guter,
hat es natürlich auch ein bisschen was mit der Bevölkerungsdichte zu tun, da sind sie ohnehin schon mal im Vorteil.
Aber eben auch was auch immer der Grund bisher dafür war einfach die Tatsache, dass ihr noch nicht so viele Fälle hatten ähm macht äh
unter einem Regime von Maßnahmen, dass wir ja trotz alledem noch haben. Äh es eben unwahrscheinlicher, dass sie so davon betroffen sind. Während eben diese ganzen äh Superspredder äh Orte.
Die wir jetzt irgendwie da hatten, was weiß ich, Oberpfalz, äh,
Nordrhein-Westfalen hier, wie hieß noch gleich der Ort Heinzberg, äh diese Region, ne? Gibt ja so ein paar paar Wiederkehrer auch in dieser Tabelle,
die müssen sich halt auch weiterhin warm äh anziehen, beziehungsweise Maske auf.
So, aber jetzt gibt's ja noch äh andere interessante, neue Erkenntnisse aus der Medizin äh und du hast dir das auch noch ein bisschen genauer angeschaut. Ich habe versucht, den ein bisschen hinterherzulesen. Ist auf jeden Fall alles sehr interessant. Die äh eine Hypothese.
Wie denn diese Krankheit eigentlich tatsächlich so funktioniert.
Mhm. Ja. Und zwar ja äh gibt's,
da eine Reihe von Papers und es wurde auch so im Frühjahr rech.
Früh damit begonnen ähm so natürlich das Virus äh und des Virusgenommen ähm.
So äh Computersimulation zu unterziehen, um,
zu sehen dann erstmal auch welche sagen welche
vom Virus zum einen produziert werden, zum anderen ähm wo sich
bestimmte
ja bestimmte Proteine wiederum auch auf dem Virus wo die sich,
lagern und wie die halt mit anderen körpereigenen Stoffen
interagieren und in in Verbindung treten. Man hat da glaube ich
über ähm irgendwie vierzigtausend Gene eingespeist aus siebzehntausend verschiedenen Proben, äh die man hatte äh und,
dann ich glaube auch ich weiß nicht über das Ganze gegen zehntausend
Stoffe, äh die so im menschlichen Stoffwechsel und im Zellstoffwechsel vorkommen, laufen lassen und geguckt so, was passt denn da äh zusammen und,
die Ergebnisse dieser Simulation äh so stärken hal.
Auch andere Vermutungen, äh, die man hatte, nämlich die sogenannte äh ja Prädigin Hypothese. Also man hat ja vermutet, schon relativ früh das,
so die eigentlichen Schäden, die das Virus hervorruft.
Durch eben eine Fehlfunktion des Immunsystems, durch den sogenannten Citokin äh äh Sturm
ausgelöst werden der vor ein paar Jahren mal in die Schlagzeilen gekommen ist bei der ähm beim Testen von
eine Medikament, wo dann plötzlich sechs Leute äh fast verstorben äh äh wären durch einen Zitokinsturm, die sind dann alle irgendwie ja das Immunsystem ist halt fach amok gelaufen und die waren dann so komplett
schwarz von oben bis unten und dick aufgequollen und so alles nicht so schön und ähm.
Hatte vermutet, dass eben sagen.
Jetzt irgendwie auch äh so etwas stattfindest, dass irgendwie das äh Virus, das Immunsystem Amok laufen lässt und dass
der eigentliche Grund ist, warum äh die Menschen sterben und das
auch eigentlich vielleicht gar nicht eine Erkältungskrankheit ist, äh sondern mehr die Blutgefäße äh angreift und eigentlich eher eine Gefäß äh Krankheit
ist und diesen klinischen Beobachtungen passen wohl jetzt ganz gut,
auch zu den Ergebnissen auch der der Simulation und dem was man halt auch weiß über.
Wie Stoffwechsel und Immunsystem funktionieren und,
geht es vor allem um den sogenannten ACE zwei Rezeptor.
Den das Virus halt angreift und dieser Rezeptor äh ist äh vor allem ja auch äh
So in den inneren Organen, im im Herz, in die Nieren und äh auch in der Lunge in höheren
Konzentration, präsent und das ist sozusagen das, wo das äh Virus dann auch äh rangeht
und was das Virus denn zusätzlich noch macht
ist, äh dass es dafür sorgt, dass andere Zellen dann auch mehr von diesen ACE zwei Rezeptoren auf ihrer Oberfläche wohl herausragen
lassen, oder? Also exprimieren oder wie man das auch äh immer nennt und das sozusagen.
Zellen, wenn,
verwundbarer machen und die Zahl aber wiederum auch der ACI zwo Rezeptoren, die die da sind, führt dann äh äh wiederum,
dazu
dass bestimmte Stoffe äh unter anderem eben äh äh die halt den sogenannten Bredikin-Level äh oder Pegel
Regeln, äh dass,
die nicht mehr richtig funktionieren und sich letztlich dieses Predigenin anreichert und ähm dieses Predigin das spielt halt auch eine Rolle im Zusammenhang dann mit.
Blutdruck und äh anderen Dingen und die eben andere ja Zytokine, es äh steht,
Predigenin auch im Zusammenhang mit Entzündungseffekten, also am Ende geht's halt auch darum, wenn das Immunsystem,
Jetzt irgendwo was bekämpfen will, sagen die Entzündung ist letztlich, dass die Zellen halt auseinanderrücken und durchlässiger werden, eigentlich
in erster Linie um bestimmte Antigene und andere Stoffe und
wenn Enzyme und so weiter das Immunsystems dann besser an den Ort zu zu bringen. So.
Also es ist eigentlich so ein so ein Notfallhormon, ne? Also.
Ist, genau, es ist.
Es ist erstmal ein Hormon haben wir noch, glaube ich, noch gar nicht äh gesagt, so und es ist auch das, was sozusagen Schmerz verursacht so, äh also es ist so quasi so eine eine dieser
Mechanismen, die einfach bei Verletzungen dann einfach aktiv werden, damit du dich drum,
kümmerst, äh, der, der Schmerz sozusagen ans Gehirn, so nach dem Motto, hier, das tut weh, kümmert dich, das ist jetzt wichtig und dann eben auch so
Jetzt müssen hier ganz viele Stoffe hin geleitet werden und dann sorgt eben dieses Hormon dafür, dass der Körper eben aufmacht und eben mehr Durchlässigkeit,
durchs Gewebe erlaubt.
Genau, was dann aber blöderweise, wenn das halt jetzt die Lunge betrifft, äh dazu führt, zum Beispiel, dass sich die Lunge dann mit Flüssigkeit füllt und blöderweise kommt dann noch ein anderer Effekt dazu, der wohl da,
dafür sorgt, dass aber diese Flüssigkeit, die dann in die Lunge.
Äh kommt auch noch geliert. Das heißt, die,
bleibt dann da, also dann so, als wenn man irgendwie versuchen wollte, durch Wackelpudding äh äh zu atmen oder so, also Lunge, die halt mit Wackelpudding gefüllt ist.
Ja. Oder das bestätigt ja sozusagen auch die Beobachtung, dass Leute, die obwohl sie dann eben extern beatmet wurden und eigentlich alles.
Hineingeblasen bekommen haben, was eben sie eigentlich bräuchten. Trotzdem äh es nicht dazu führt, dass auch alles erreicht wird. Und das hat einfach mit der Verstopfung dann zu tun.
Auch andere, also neurologische Effekte sagen,
Verlust von Geschmack und Geruch, auch dafür sind sagen ACE-Hemmer bekannt, dass die das hervorrufen,
und andere Dinge, also es passt halt ganz, ganz gut,
Also diese Erklärungen scheinen,
wo mir zumindest relativ logisch äh zu sein und erklären halt
ganz viele der
Dinge, die etwas mysteriös waren bisher, warum Leute denen es gut gingen plötzlich auch so verstorbenen, warum es das Herz angreift äh und so und auch,
warum das dann das Gehirn auch äh angreifen kann, weil nämlich auch die Bluthirnschranke äh,
durch hohe Prediginin Level überwunden werden kann, äh äh dann, weil da aufgemacht wird, also ja, da passt halt eine ganze,
Menge und,
gute ist, dass es halt eben dadurch aber auch eine ganze Menge Behandlungsansätze gibt, weil eigentlich ist das,
ist wohl dieser Teil des Immunsystems recht gut verstanden äh und.
Da treten auch andere Krankheiten auf und speziell so ACE-Hemmer spielen natürlich bei Blueto
Regulation eine eine wichtige Rolle, das heißt es ist ein ganz gut untersuchtes Feld mit einer Menge zugelassener Medikamente, die gegen verschiedene äh dieser,
Probleme auch äh helfen, die halt äh so dass das mir zumindest eine gewisse Hoffnung äh äh gibt
dass äh man sagen, dass das Virus langsam
und und wie es wirkt, immer besser verstanden wird und.
Äh daher auch schwere Verläufe vielleicht weitgehend auch,
zu verhindern sein könnten, wenn sich das jetzt so alles erhärtet und wir haben dann mehr Erfahrung sammelt.
Freue mich so ein bisschen diese Studie äh und Untersuchung, das ist ja ausm Juli und äh trotzdem.
Gibt's jetzt erst Berichterstattung dadrüber so richtig, also ich weiß nicht, äh gab's da nochmal einen nachgelagerten Veröffentlichungsprozess, der das jetzt erst äh
wird dich halt sichtbar werden lassen oder ist er hat es einfach so lange gedauert bis das auch in diese wissenschaftliche Journalismus Ecke reingesickert ist, war so ein ganzer Monat, ist er für so ein Korona Thema doch ziemlich äh fett.
Ja gut, unklar, ich glaube, es kam noch dazu, also man hatte jetzt dann irgendwie auch noch fertig gerechnet, also ich äh.
Ja, aber das hat wohl auch im im Juli stattgefunden. Also, das mit dem Rechnen sollte man vielleicht nochmal erwähnen, ist nämlich ganz interessant, da äh wurde nämlich ein super Computer ähm zum Einsatz gebracht.
Äh der also auch in dieser sogenannten Top Five handelt äh Liste drin ist, der Okrich,
Ähm Okrich National Leveritury, äh der Rechner heißt Summit.
Und äh ist derzeit in der Top Five Hundred Liste, also der fünfhundert leistungsfähigsten Computer der Welt äh auf Platz zwei.
Und ähm das ist eine Maschine, die hat zwei Komma vier Millionen CPUs.
Also zwei Komma vier Millionen äh Cors, also.
Da waren mehrere Koalen sollen da CPU drin, aber auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge. Also große Halle voll mit irgendwie eine echt schnellen Rechnern und so und das äh geht schon äh fix, trotzdem waren sie da eine Woche am Rechner. Was sie da gemacht haben war.
Korrigiere mich äh.
Dass sie jetzt quasi so die Eigenschaft dieses Virus genommen haben, also womit das Ding quasi äh auch an diese ganzen ACE Moleküle und so weiter äh äh rangeht. Normalerweise, also wie es sich ausbreitet und haben das mehr oder weniger auf
alle Proteine, die so im Körper äh sind an.
Mhm. Ja, auf eine Liste, ich glaube von zehntausend Proteinen äh.
Und das ist dann so quasi so eine Dreidimensionale Verschränkung dieser dieser äh Proteinstrukturen und dann rechnet man das einfach durch, was kann jetzt an was ranpassen und daraus haben die dann quasi das abgeleitet. Das heißt, diese
tiefen Erkenntnis, vielleicht auch ausgehend mit ein paar Annahmen, Beobachtungen war quasi einfach datengetrieben. Das haben wir wirklich jetzt,
mal durchgerechnet, so Blutforce mit okay, wir werfen dich jetzt mal hier auf Mensch. Mensch enthält im Wesentlichen das oder gibt natürlich noch,
sehr viel mehr als zehntausend Proteine, aber das sind sagen wir mal die wichtigsten oder die kennt man oder was weiß ich. Und dann äh wird es halt verglichen, wo passt du rein und was hast du da für eine was was bewirkst du da.
Ja. Wobei ich, wenn ich das richtig äh verstanden habe, man sogar noch einen Schritt weiter gegangen ist und sagen vom genommen ausgegangen ist. Das heißt, geguckt hat, sagen welche ja.
RNA-Sequenzen äh sind jetzt da und welche Stoffe äh werden äh durch
diese welche ja Proteine werden durch diese RNA eigentlich
produziert, das heißt man hat sozusagen tatsächlich eine Simulation auf genetischer Ebene äh äh sogar ist noch davor gekommen, das heißt hat halt, ja.
Eben sagt auch die die Proteine, die zumindest vom äh vom Virus selbst dann produziert äh werden, hat man halt simuliert,
ja indem man sagen, dass man so will, dass Virus ein Stück weit das Virus selbst simuliert hat, wie es halt äh ja,
mit Genen mit den Horst Genen auch interagiert und so.
Ja, was bedeutet das jetzt? Also ich meine, wenn das stimmt oder wenn ich meine, was stimmt, also wenn die Ergebnisse dieser Studie.
Auch weiterhin einer Überprüfung standhalten und oder zumindest gute Basis für weitere Studien äh liefert.
Ist erstmal ein interessantes Erklärungsmuster, also man hat eine genauere Vorstellung davon, wie sich das Virus in den menschlichen Körper so eingräbt.
Und warum es diese ganzen Auswirkungen gibt, aber das bedeutet ja dann im Umkehrschluss auch, dass man dann weiß, okay, was alles angegriffen wird, dann kann man natürlich auch sehr viel effizienter über Gegenmaßnahmen.
Nachdenken.
Das ist, das ist sozusagen der der Punkt
Ich äh sagte, dass halt eine ganze Menge von den Funktionen des Immunsystems ganz gut verstanden ist und dass man eine ganze Menge Medikamente, also über zehn Medikamente
zugelassen sind hat, die sich als hilfreich herausstellen könnten äh im Zusammenhang mit der Bekämpfung von Symptomen.
Zur Bekämpfung halt ähm schwerer Verläufe. Also mir gibt es äh jedenfalls so eine gewisse Hoffnung, dass auch äh vor allen Dingen
entmystifiziert ist für mich auch so ein bisschen das das Virus, weil es war ja immer vorher irgendwie mal so, ja. Aber
okay, ja, es greift die Lunge an und dann aber, warum die Leute plötzlich so schnell sterben und warum Beatmung dann auch nicht funktioniert
und
warum dann es Herzinfarkt gibt und wieso eigentlich die Nerven angegriffen werden und so. Das war alles so ein bisschen mysteriös und ich finde halt so ein mysteriöses
Virus, was Dinge tut, die man nicht versteht, eigentlich etwas unheimlicher und gefährlicher
Also ich weiß, okay, es geht halt überall dorthin, wo halt äh ähm Zellen sind, die in höherem Maße irgendwie ACE zwo, Rezeptoren exprimieren, die werden halt angegriffen, dann ja
weiß man halt okay das passiert und dann wenn die angegriffen werden, dann hat das die und die Folgen die dann tödlich sein können und dann hat weiß man halt gleich
wo man dann ansetzen kann, mit welcher Art von Medikamenten, um das zu stoppen.
Einfach oder um zumindest dann ja die die fatalen Auswirkungen zu stopp.
So, jetzt gibt's äh natürlich auch wieder viel Diskussion über.
Wie sich denn dieses Virus außerhalb des Körpers äh denn verhält, also was macht uns denn jetzt eigentlich wirklich zum äh Infektionsopfer.
Und jetzt blicken wir auf so eine lange, lange Phase zurück, wo halt irgendwie ja Abstand waren, so ein bisschen das Primat der der Vorsicht war.
Am Anfang war's ja putzen. Am Anfang war's ja irgendwie äh so ähm ja äh Desinfektionsmittel und ähm.
Alles reinigen und nichts anfassen äh äh draußen, Achtung, keine Türgriffe ablecken und so.
Genau, aber das ist so im Wesentlichen die äh die Erfahrung so von Noroviren und so, ne? Wenn da irgendwie Scheißerei in der Kita ist und so weiter, besser mal alle Hände waschen und so, das hilft dann schon mal äh äh eine ganze Menge,
beziehungsweise generell natürlich kann das eben sein. Dann ging's aber relativ schnell auf diese Spuckerei und das war ja ein bisschen auch dieses Aufkommen dieses Spuckschutzes. Gibt ja immer noch ein paar Leute, die rennen irgendwie standen mit einer Maske mit so einem poschen,
Gesichtspuckschutzdings rum so.
Ich denke, es zeichnet sich jetzt im zunehmendem Maße ab und wir haben das ja hier auch schon mehrfach eigentlich vermutet, ne, dass die Sache wirklich eher eine Frage von äh Ariosohlen ist. So und äh,
das müsste jetzt eigentlich auch dazu führen, dass dass wir eben auch unsere Vorsitzmaßnahmen entsprechend anpassen.
Ja, ich meine gut, das mit den Ariosolen hatten wir ja ganz ganz früh tatsächlich hier im im Podcast, also
Wochen, Monate, bevor das äh ich glaube sogar schon Ende April oder Anfang Mai oder so hatten wir,
haben wir, also ja, in der zweiten oder dritten Sendung, glaube ich, hatten wir dann schon äh darüber gesprochen, wobei
man natürlich eine Sache vielleicht auch.
Beachten muss, wenn man so dem Virus durch bestimmte Vorsichtsmaßnahme, Schutzmaßnahmen eine Art von Verbreitung jetzt massiv,
erschwert. Ja, das ist, was ich durch Masken, wenn alle Masken tragen und,
jetzt nicht mehr spucken können, dann hat das Virus jetzt mit Übertragung durch große Tröpfchen,
ein Problem, ja. Äh
Aber es kann ja natürlich sein, dass es sich dann gewissermaßen andere Verbreitungswege äh sucht. Ja äh das ist gewissermaßen ausweicht, wenn man äh wenn man so will, also jetzt nicht.
Jetzt aktiv, weil es denkt, ah hier komm ich nicht weiter, jetzt muss ich woanders hin, sondern dass ich halt ja, wenn man ein Ding zu macht, dass äh dann andere Verbreitungswege, die auch dann mit verhalten und anderen zu tun haben,
können. Insofern ja kann sich das natürlich durchaus auch tatsächlich verlagern, wie sich das Virus,
ausbreitet. Einmal weil sich das Virus verändert, aber auch wenn sich das Verhal,
äh verändert ähm ja.
Perspektivisch, ne? Aber die Frage ist natürlich, was was macht man derzeit eigentlich richtig? Was macht man äh nicht richtig? Und ähm ich wollte das jetzt auch einfach
gar nicht in aller Tiefe durchdiskutieren, sondern nur einfach mal so ein bisschen aus den den Stand der Dinge so ein bisschen fest,
halten, weil ich denke, was man jetzt sehr klar sagen kann, ist.
Die größte Gefahr geht aus von einem Ort, der schlecht gelüftet ist.
Wo äh sich andere Leute befinden, alle keine Maske tragen und äh auch noch alle viel äh atmen.
In der Regel ja immer äh schlimmer noch reden, genau äh oder noch schlimmer im Schreien und singen. Also so eine.
Laute Kneipe, schlecht gelüftet im Winter.
Alle irgendwie eng beieinander sind und so weiter, also das ist einfach mal schon fast,
eine Garantie so, ne? Und wenn äh alle dann eine eine Maske tragen, dann ist es immer noch äh schlimm.
Ähm dann kommen wir aber in gewisser Hinsicht auch nochmal auf diese Frage mit dieser Sterblichkeit zurück, was nämlich auch noch so ein äh Faktor sein kann.
Jetzt äh gibt's ja äh.
Wenn man so ein durch den Supermarktloch oder überhaupt wo Leute quasi Masken tragen und Zug und so wissen wir ja alle gibt's ja dann so diese verschiedenen Arten und Weisen eine Maske zu tragen, ne? Maske und,
Nase äh aber was vielleicht auch noch ein Problem ist, was viele Leute nicht sehen, das sind so schlecht anliegende Masken.
Und was man sich klar machen muss ist,
natürlich die Maske wunderbar diese unmittelbaren Spritzariosohle ähm aufhängt, also was heißt Aresol, also,
dem Moment, wo man halt äh spricht und so weiter, also quasi die normal feuchte Aussprache hat eine relativ äh hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit. In der Maske hängen zu bleiben, ne. Wenn ich aber jetzt einatme und das ist ja eigentlich so das Kernproblem.
Was jetzt die eigene Infektion betrifft, dann muss diese Luft ja irgendwo herkommen und wenn die Maske halt schlecht anliegt, dann sieht man sich eben die, die äh die Luft von oben oder eben von der Seite, ne? Gibt's ja dann oft so Leute
haben die Masken dann so links und rechts
quasi offen ähm ne und denken irgendwie, ja, wenn man mal den Mund nicht sieht, dann bin ich wohl auch schon äh geschützt, aber das bedeutet im Prinzip, dass man eben die Raumluft einfach mit reinnimmt.
Und wir haben ja vorhin schon über die Sterblichkeit gesprochen, dass die eben äh niedriger ist und verschiedene Gründe genannt. Ein weiterer Grund äh kann eben sein.
Dass eben auch die Virusmenge, die man aufnimmt, sehr viel damit zu tun hat. Das heißt, selbst, wenn ich mich jetzt in einem Raum befinde, wo irgendjemand infiziert ist.
Und ich habe aber eine Maske auf und die Maske liegt eng an. Dann kann's natürlich immer noch sein,
dass sich in irgendeiner Form, weil die ist ja nicht hemetisch abgeschlossen, die Maske, es gibt natürlich auch enge anliegende Masken, was weiß ich, äh wie heißen die äh fünfundneunzig äh,
bla, die äh Begriffe vergessen, egal. Auf jeden Fall äh selbst wenn ich Viren einatme.
Und dann auch dadurch vielleicht infiziert werde, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man weniger Virus aufnimmt.
Natürlich entsprechend höher und schon ganz zu Anfang könnte man ja auch sehen,
wenn Leute so eine so eine volle Dosis genommen haben. Also angenommen, die äh hustet jetzt einer so voll infektiös, so richtig
dein Gesicht ein und genau in dem Moment nimmst du mal so einen ganz tiefen Schluck Luft so, dann beförderst du dir alle in die Lunge und das ist schon mal ganz schlecht
So in dem Moment, wo sie aber eben nur in einer dünnen Dosis da sind, kann es zwar sein, dass die Krankheit ausbricht, aber es zeig,
jetzt wohl auch, dass dann eben auch die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass diese Krankheit einen milderen Verlauf hat
zunimmt. Also man kann's gar nicht oft genug sagen. Masken sind einfach mit Abstand der beste Schutz in dieser ganzen Situation.
Mir ist es übrigens als, ich glaube, dass es in der Grundschule äh ist mir das mal passiert, dass mich jemand direkt angehustet hat, ein anderes Kind so,
aus, ich weiß nicht
Ja, vielleicht zwanzig, dreißig Zentimetern Entfernung plötzlich ohne irgendwie, also direkt ins Gesicht gehustet hat und ich war gerade irgendwie am Einatmen
und
Abend lag ich dann flach für mehrere Tage, also es war sagendes einzige und erstmal mich erinnern kann äh so genau
an dem Moment, wo mich, wo ich wahrscheinlich infiziert worden bin, äh, durch jemand, der mich direkt angehustet hat, so das,
war irgendwie so ja so offensichtlich in dem Moment.
Das machst du jetzt am besten nicht mehr.
Nee, nee, also was ja, was trägst du denn für Masken eigentlich.
Ich trage eigentlich so normalen OP Masken.
Und zwar, weil ich einfach dann irgendwann mal, als es dann möglich war bei äh Amazon mir so ein.
Was weiß ich, hundert Masken für zwanzig Euro Stapel gekauft habe. Ich dachte mir so viel hilft viel und hab einfach so größere Vorratspakete, also an allen strategischen Orten
verteilt, so bei mir im Büro, in der Wohnung, in irgendwelchen Taschen im Auto
so weiter, also dass man sozusagen immer wenn man so diese oh Scheiße, keine Maske dabei im Moment hat, dass man einfach
auch irgendwo so 'n frischen Block reingreifen kann und zack hat man wieder eine. Das kann ich auch jedem nur empfehlen, funktioniert wunderbar und ehrlich gesagt, ich finde diese OP Masken eigentlich auch, also meine Sehnen vielleicht sieht es nicht schick aus.
Ja? Aber wenn man sich äh davon trennen kann, finde ich sie einfach extrem praktisch, weil sie sind leicht.
Sie lassen sich gut so äh an den an die Körperformen äh an äh passen.
Speziell wenn man mit dem Metall mit so einem mit dem Blechstreifen oben über die Nase, den man dann einfach.
Genau gut knicken kann und und ich finde, man kann halt auch relativ gut durchatmen.
Der Atemwiderstand ist nicht so hoch wie bei anderen äh Masken und gleichzeitig kann man aber sicher sein, dass äh das Fließ, was da drin ist, äh einfach dicht
genug ist, äh, um seinen Zweck zu erfüllen, was man halt.
Das ist Proven Technology. Ich meine Ärzte benutzen das einfach äh schon lange und seitdem es sowas äh gibt, gibt's halt auch bei OPs halt weniger Infektionen, ne.
Damit schützen sie ja sozusagen dann eben auch die Operierten. Also ich hab da kein Problem mit und die Verfügbarkeit von Maske ist auf jeden Fall immer ein klarer Bonus.
Also ich bin genau zu dem selben,
zu denselben Schlüssen gekommen und habe mir zwar woanders irgendwie in dem Fall den Motorradladen äh an der Kasse hatten sie so einen fünfziger Pack auch für zwanzig Euro oder so, das da habe ich dann zugeschlagen und,
äh ja. Fand das dann auch ähm sehr, sehr
angenehm. Vielleicht wichtig ist dann aber noch auch, dass man sich vielleicht nochmal ins äh Bewusstsein ruft, dann auch so ein bisschen Maskenhygiene, also für die Dinger dann halt ähm beim Aufsetzen und beim Absetzen halt nur an den äh an den Straps
äh äh halt hält, wenn beim beim Aufsetzen und beim Absetzen und
auch nicht so viel auf der Maske dann irgendwie drauf äh rumgrabbelt.
Ja und vor allem wenn sie halt irgendwie äh anfängt irgendwie pickig auszusehen, zack, bumm, weg damit und die nächste, vielleicht nicht äh gerade in den Garten schmeißen. Na ja.
Gut, äh, das wird uns nachher, wenn wir über die Corona Warneb äh sprechen, auch nochmal beschäftigen dieses Thema.
So auch als Follow ab zu der letzten Diskussion die wir ja hatten um diese Idee im Fußball vielleicht mit mehr Tests.
Kommen. Gibt da noch ganz interessante Sachen und zwar ist ähm letzte Woche vor zwei Wochen oder so, gab so ein Test.
Konzert, also in Leipzig irgendwie mit äh Tim Benzko, und so ein äh Musiker.
Und äh da haben sie dann freiwillige quasi eingeladen, sind nicht so viele gekommen, wie sie äh gerne gehabt hätten. Es waren so einige hundert.
Und ähm dann haben sie äh in so einer Halle halt dieses Konzert durchgeführt und das Ganze aber sozusagen als wissenschaftliches Experiment,
durchgeführt, also alle hatten irgendwie M,
auf und dann wussten sie halt genau, wer da reingeht und wer wo sitzt und so weiter, um einfach irgendwie ähm.
Ergebnisse zu erzielen, Erkenntnisse zu erzielen, was denn da jetzt sozusagen passiert bei so einer Veranstaltung, natürlich das die Veranstaltungsbranche wie kaum eine andere.
Von dieser ganzen Pandimie,
unter Beschuss geraten ist so, also ich meine, wer will jetzt schon auf große Veranstaltungen? Keiner, so ist es nahezu alles abgesagt worden, es ist nicht nur das, was am meisten betroffen ist oder ist ja generell eigentlich in dieser Akademie, also alles, was von Anfang an stark betroffen war.
Ist auch so potenziell das letzte was äh wieder aufgenommen wird, ne? Also Kneipenbars et cetera.
Werden also noch eine harte Zeit haben und Veranstaltungen stehen da irgendwie an letzter Stelle, von dem was man sich dann irgendwie unbedingt wieder äh wünscht, ne? Na ja, auf jeden Fall sowas findet äh statt und dann hatten wir ja auch über.
Fußball äh gesprochen, interessanterweise sind mittlerweile in Berlin äh wieder Fußballspiele mit Zuschauern möglich.
Sofern es sich dabei eben nicht um Bundesligaspiele handelt.
Weil die Bundesliga sich selbst jetzt sozusagen äh da eine Limitierung.
Aufgeklebt hat, das ist aber alles noch so ein bisschen im im Fluss, also das weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau. Tatsache, ich hatte ja das Beispiel FC Union in Berlin äh genannt, was ich natürlich besonders verfolge, weil ich bin ja Mitglied in diesem Verein und.
Sehe, dass sie sich da auch extrem mühen zu interessanten Vorschlägen zu kommen, nicht nur für Fußball, sondern generell für Veranstaltungen, weil sie auch an sich auch Veranstalter sind. Das Stadion ist ja sozusagen auch ein Veranstaltungsort. Betrifft sie also auch über den Fußball hinaus.
Und da wird's jetzt an diesem Wochenende, also in zwei Tagen
tatsächlich ein Fußballspiel geben mit maximal fünftausend Leuten im Stadion, also ungefähr so viereinhalbtausend Zuschauer plus halt, wer sonst eben da noch alles mit rumläuft, Ordner und so weiter.
Wird man mal sehen, dann halt mit Masken.
Ihr Vorschlag war ja testen und dann eben auch unter Umständen noch mehr Leute und das hatten sie auch beantragt. Das ist dann erstmal Oktober verschoben worden, weil sich dann, weil es eher eine bürokratische Frage ist. Also sie wollten's eigentlich im September machen.
Mittesten.
Und dann war das aber, sagen wir mal, in dem bis jetzt Ende Oktober beschlossenen Konzept so rechtlich nicht vorgesehen.
Und weil das nicht vorgesehen war, lassen sie die Tests jetzt einfach weg.
Aber dafür halt mit Basken. Ja, also das war ja sozusagen mit Tests und ohne Maske, Versus jetzt eben.
Ohne Tests mit Maske. Na ja, also wir werden sozusagen,
Fußballspiele sehen, wo Zuschauer Masken haben in Leipzig ist es ähnlich.
Da gab's jetzt auch für die Bundesliga ähm schon die erste Zusage, dass sie das Stadion zu zwanzig Prozent füllen dürfen.
Aber nur auf Sitzplätzen et cetera.
Mit Abstand und so weiter. Also das wird auf jeden Fall sein, aber zumindest wird's mal wieder ein paar Lautäußerungen äh geben können.
Ich bin gespannt äh wie das so läuft.
Ich auch gut mit, ich sag mal ja wird man sehen mit viertel gefüllten Stadien und so und ja hm.
Bevor wir äh nochmal zu der Frage der Tests kommen.
Noch zwei kleine Meldungen, die ich ganz interessant fand, äh hast du das mitbekommen auf
Röhrinseln gab's ja erst lange Zeit überhaupt gar keine Fälle, dann hatten sie welche.
Hatten da so einen Ausbruch und dann haben sie ja beschlossen, das Ganze so richtig granatenhart kaputt zu kämpfen, so ähnlich wie Neuseeland das auch gemacht hat und da sind,
alle getestet worden. Also Verrührinseln,
Ich weiß jetzt gerade gar nicht wie viele Einwohner die haben, das schlage ich mal kurz nach auf den Inseln leben.
Einundfünfzigtausenddreihunderteinundsiebzig Person.
Ähm ja, kleine Insel, ne? Ist ja auch nicht so attraktiv da. Jetzt äh.
Unbedingt hinzuziehen,
für die meisten, die suchen sich dann doch vielleicht eine Wohnung in Barcelona, auf jeden Fall auf Pfarrüber Inseln fünfzigtausend und sie haben jetzt sich komplett Cowit frei gemacht, indem sie innerhalb von zwei Wochen irgendwie alle getestet haben.
Also wir haben so richtig äh Gas gegeben. Gut, fünfzigtausend Tests, das ist halt in gewisser Hinsicht auch noch zu machen, ja? Also mit äh achtzig Millionen Leuten in Deutschland hätte das glaube ich äh.
Nicht mit nicht mit PCA, äh ja beziehungsweise ja.
Da brauchst du einfach ganz andere Kapazitäten, ganz andere Materialmengen, et cetera, trotzdem interessant, dass sie das eben äh gemacht haben und mittlerweile sind sie also frei, also sie haben jetzt sozusagen, glaube ich, eine Woche oder so keine Fälle mehr
und gehen jetzt äh schon im Wesentlichen davon aus, dass sie das Problem beendet haben. Aber äh sie haben jetzt nicht nur getestet, um gut frei zu werden, sondern sie
machen auch noch, glaube ich, eine Gensequenzierung über alle.
Personen auf den Pfarrer hören, also jeder der getestet wurde, hat auch noch ein G-Test quasi also,
Sample abgegeben, um äh das zu sequenzieren. Das heißt, sie wollen dann eben bei den Leuten, die dann eben auch noch einen Ausbruch hatten, et cetera oder eben auch nicht infiziert wurden in Infektionssituationen.
Das Ganze eben auch nochmal genitisch überprüfen. Dann gibt's da natürlich jetzt noch keine Ergebnisse, aber das fand ich irgendwie ganz interessant. Zweite, interessante Meldung fand ich.
Ähm ist die Situation in Afrika. Und wir haben ja auch schon so nebenbei so ein bisschen darüber gesprochen und wir hatten wir alle so ein bisschen die Befürchtung so, oh mein Gott, Land mit schlecht ausgebauten Gesundheitssystemen.
Ja die Leute wohnen eng beisammen.
Viele Situationen, ne, wo einfach Leute einfach mit vielen Leuten in einem Raum leben und das war ja irgendwie so ein Desaster, was was auf einen zurollte, dachte man.
Stellt sich raus, sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Südafrika, ich glaub es geht generell für Afrika.
Hat enorm niedrige Infektionszahlen auch in äh sehr niedrige äh Sterbezahlen. Und diese Überlastung des des Gesundheitssystems hat sich so nicht eingestellt.
Und alle Wissenschaftler so, hey, so, was, was bitte.
Was erlaube Afrika, also irgendwie ja das äh was soll denn bei euch bitte jetzt anders sein.
Als in Europa et cetera, wo ihr doch so schlechte Bedingungen habt eigentlich für diesen Virus.
Und klar, man muss jetzt nochmal sehen, wie lange das anhält, aber es ist halt einfach so nach Adam Riese, hätte, hätte es im Prinzip schon ganz schlimm sein müssen.
Und man fragt sich halt jetzt, was sind der Grund dafür sein kann.
Und eine These ist, dass äh der Grund, dass es so äh.
Dass es nicht schlimm ist, obwohl äh sie so schlechte Voraussetzungen haben, sich vor allem Virus zu schützen, dass der Grund daran äh darin liegt, dass sie so schlechte Voraussetzungen haben, sich vor dem Virus zu schützen.
Wie.
Und zwar nicht nur vor dem Virus, sondern vor allen Viren. Sie gehen also davon aus, dass in dieser Bevölkerung Corona Viren anderer Bauart.
Schon immer so eine massive Durchsäuchung nach sich gezogen haben. Also,
also alle Schnupfen gehabt haben, alle hatten alle hatten alle Viren.
Wir ja klar, man wird mal krank und so, aber man hat ja Mittelchen, man geht den Leuten.
Aus dem Weg und man hat Taschentücher und manchmal trägt er vielleicht auch mal eine Maske, das wird sich glaube ich nächstes Jahr dann auch ändern oder in Zukunft nicht. Ich denke, wir werden das dann äh bei uns auch künftig mal so wieder so erleben, wie wie das vielleicht in
Asien schon äh öfter Usus ist, dass wenn man irgendwie Schnupfen hat und so weiter sitzt man halt so eine Maske auf, um andere Leute zu schützen. Das setzt sich ja hier langsam auch durch, aber
Es ist die Vermutung, dass einfach in Afrika andere Korona Viren schon so sehr die Bevölkerung durchseucht haben,
dass sich hier etwas zeigt, was man ja auch für Saß äh Kuff zwei,
Schon die ganze Zeit vermutet hat, aber eben immer noch nicht so richtig weiß, dass nämlich unter Umständen.
Die Infektion mit anderen Poronaviren auch so eine Grundimunität schafft.
Die.
Hintergrundimmunität.
Genau, so eine
genau, die hinter, das ist der richtige Begriff, den habe ich gesucht, genau. Das so eine Hintergrundimmunität äh ausgelöst wird durch andere Corona-Viren und dadurch, dass in Afrika einfach generell sich alles so wunderbar ausbreiten kann. Diese Hintergrundimmunität viel stärker ist
Als wir sie zum Beispiel hier in Europa haben.
Also quasi die Tatsache, dass wir uns so gut vor dem Viren schützen, hat dazu geführt, dass wir uns nicht so gut vor Viren schützen können.
Ja, was dann natürlich ja Schlimmes äh für die Zukunft dann, wo wir uns jetzt alle noch weiter jetzt vor allen möglichen anderen Viren schützen, könnten wir irgendwie,
Beweisfecht in zwei, drei oder vier Jahren irgendwie so eine Horrorgrippe äh äh Welle oder so äh kriegen, weil irgendwie die
aktuellen Grippeviren keine Chance äh hatten hier durchzulaufen. Äh normalerweise ist da so diese Grippewellen
hängen ja glaube ich auch viel damit zusammen, dass halt immer eine neue.
Junge Bevölkerung nachwächst, die halt noch nicht Immun ist und wenn da immer so eine kritische Masse erreicht ist, sozusagen, dann,
kann halt mal wieder so eine Welle durch, so wie bei,
bei Waldbränden, wo dann halt äh ja
äh auch wenn wenn da lange kein Brand war, dann liegt da halt verdammt viel trockenes Gestrüpp äh rum, sodass die Waldbrände dann irgendwie schlimmer werden, ja.
Also.
Wir werden sehen. Ja, wenn ich mal nicht gucke, guck jetzt gerade mal auf die Zahlen für Südafrika, die hatten da bisher tatsächlich nur eine Welle,
ja? Äh so die halt hochgegangen ist und dann aber jetzt wieder relativ weit runter gegangen ist auf zweitausend Fälle am Tag, wo sie zwischenzeitlich mal bei vierzehntausend.
Warten.
Wenn wir gerade schon dabei sind, ich mein die USA ist jetzt bei se,
Komma eins Millionen Fällen und hundertfünfundachtzig.
Tote.
Es ist schon heftig wobei,
und sagen kann, dass es da jetzt auch, ich meine, die USA hatten halt erstmal so die erste Welle, dann ging's leicht runter und dann hat's nochmal ordentlich angezogen auf.
Irgendwie achtzigtausend, danach, gut, wir haben jetzt keine Testzahlen
So wurde ja auch viel darüber geredet, dass komischerweise die Zahlen zurückgegangen sind, äh nachdem Donald Trump angeordnet hat, dass sich jetzt nicht mehr das CDC um die Zahlen kümmert, sondern irgendeine andere Behörde und,
schon gegen die Zahlen runter, aber äh ja, sie sind jedenfalls noch jedenfalls noch weit entfernt, ähm noch nicht mal.
Auf dem unter den Höhepunkt der ersten Welle wieder gefallen, sondern sind jetzt so bei.
Irgendwie vierzigtausend neuen Fällen pro Tag größenordnungsmäßig. Das ist natürlich schon heftig.
Ja, es ist ja auch zu einem Kulturkrieg der besonderen Art ausgeartet und die halt jetzt im November die Wahlen sind, das macht die Sache halt auch nicht besser, sondern eigentlich eher noch schlimmer.
Völlig entglitten dieses Land. So, es ist äh also auf jeder Ebene, also man man kann sich einfach wirklich nur noch äh wundern. Aber na ja gut.
Außenpolitik brauchen wir uns jetzt hier glaube ich nicht groß zu äußern, aber an der Stelle kann ich ja mal planen. Ich habe ich habe einen äh einen alten Podcast von mir wieder aufgenommen.
Ähm der vier Jahre lang brach lag, News of the World mit Bicicle Mark auf Englisch. Äh er ist ja,
Amerikaner und Portugiese und wohnt in Amsterdam. Also es geht äh kaum äh internationaler bei ihm und begleitet auch diese ganzen politischen Geschehnisse auf aller Welt äh immer wieder. Da haben wir uns natürlich auch viel,
darüber unterhalten, wie es denn gerade in USA so abgeht, aber das jetzt mal so.
Nebenbei. Zurück zu Corona.
Testing Testing, Testing, ja,
Was ja äh auch eine große äh Frage ist, das kam jetzt auch beim Drosten auf, da weiß ich nicht mehr ganz genau, was er in seinem deutschen Podcast gesagt hat, aber er war jetzt auch nochmal zu Gast in so einem internationalen This Week in Virus, äh Disweg in Virollogy,
irgendwie so ein typischer äh ja,
YouTube mit entsprechenden Gesichtern, da war dann irgendwie äh zu Gast habe ich nicht ganz durchgehört, aber auch da kam nochmal diese Frage auf und ich glaube, es war auch in dem äh Corona Virus äh äh Podcast,
drin.
Die Frage nach den Antigentests, ne? Also wir reden ja bei den ganzen Tests bisher immer nur von dem PCR-Tests.
Ähm ja, ne, quasi so das sicherste äh Ding sind, aber eben relativ hohen Aufwand haben,
Und die sogenannten Antigentests, die äh versprechen ja im Prinzip eine einfachere Testung.
Mit unmittelbaren Ergebnissen, ne? Also im Idealfall halt diese Schwangerschaftsstreifen, dieser Flow äh Tests bis hin eben zu, dass man da äh nur noch den äh Speichel.
Analysiert,
skeptisch, also bevorzugt da doch lieber einen ordentlichen Rachenabstrich, also dass man sozusagen auch wirklich ordentlich von dort abnimmt, wo man auch viel Virus vermutet oder wo in der Regel äh viel,
da ist, wenn man denn jetzt infiziert ist, aber davon abgesehen sind die halt einfach äh einerseits noch nicht so richtig zugelassen,
hier in Deutschland.
Und in den USA gibt's wohl jetzt immer mehr Anbieter, die mit solchen Tests da auf den Markt kommen. Aber es ist alles noch nicht so richtig.
Noch nicht da so und so wie ich das mitbekommen habe, bezweifelt,
auch, dass dass diese äh Test in ausreichenden Mengen verfügbar werden.
Ja, Rosch it's,
gut, es gibt ja mehrere Anbieter, ich hatte vor allem ist jetzt, war jetzt Rosch in den Schlagzeilen, dass sie mit äh so einem Test äh jetzt kommen wollen, ähm.
Und die wollten irgendwie sowas von eine Million Test,
pro Monat oder so produzieren oder bis Ende des Jahres irgendwie jedenfalls ja
auch nicht äh wirklich so die Mengen, wo man jetzt sagen würde, da kann man jetzt komplett die gesamte deutsche Bevölkerung mit durchtesten
und was ich auch gehört habe,
war von einem solchen Test, dass der jetzt zurückgerufen wurde. Ich glaube, das war auch in den in den USA oder in
England, wo man angefangen hatte, damit zu testen und äh aber dann sehr schnell festgestellt hat, dass die Ergebnisse viel zu unbrauchbar sind, also viel zu.
Ähm ja unspezifisch äh das Ganze und äh deswegen hat man das dann wohl gestoppt äh wieder äh die Dinger zu benutzen,
für den Zweck, aber man wird sehen, ja.
Ich sehe gerade Rosch äh wirbt auch so mit sechsundneunzig Komma fünf,
Sensitivität. Also.
Da liegen auch die PCR-Tests, also das äh muss man dann sehen. Äh im Wesentlichen ist es eine Frage des Preises. Also wenn die Dinger für fünfzig Euro rauskommen, dann ist das natürlich irgendwie Quatsch,
wenn die Dinger halt für fünf Euro oder weniger auf den Markt kommen, dann wird's natürlich auf einmal interessant, weil,
Ich denke, diese ADG-Test abgesehen davon, dass sie halt schnell ein Ergebnis liefern, werden sich vor allem dadurch dann eben
nützlich machen, indem man einfach oft testet, weil ja sein, dass da mal ein falsches Ergebnis dabei ist, aber wenn du jeden Tag eins machst.
Dann wird sich das natürlich auch darüber entsprechend stabilisieren. Und ja, ich äh ich hoffe, äh dass es dazu kommt, aber.
Werden wir sehen, ne? Also auch die Spezifität, dass äh man also wirklich auch was erkennt, das liegt bei neunundneunzig Komma sechs acht Prozent.
Laut Rosh, klingt jetzt auch erstmal nicht so schlecht, also äh am Ende ist es eine eine Preisfrage, ne.
Aber Preise ähm gibt's noch nicht. Test gibt's noch nicht. Preise gibt's noch nicht. Alles viel.
Ankündigung und wenig konkretes.
Wo wir vielleicht ja.
Fällt mir gerade nur ein Thema Testso vielleicht zwei Sachen noch so ein bisschen vielleicht ja ich weiß nicht die ob die Banken äh.
Nicht fast zu viel äh gesagt ist, aber mir sind, also es gibt so zwei Dinge, die mir auch in den letzten Wochen immer wieder auf Twitter,
untergekommen
sind, wo ähm gerade aus, ich sage mal, äh der Ecke von Corona, Zweiflern oder Korona Leugnern oder wie auch immer ähm.
Und das eine war immer das Thema falsch positive Tests, äh weiß nicht, wie viel wir hier schon äh im Podcast darüber gesprochen äh haben, aber.
Gangs haben wir, glaube ich, sehr viel über die Problematik gesprochen, um über erstmal die Begriffe zu sortieren, aber in letzter Zeit nicht.
Ja, ja. Und das, das kam halt immer wieder hoch von aus ganz verschiedensten Ecken, das gesagt wurde, na ja ähm.
Die äh Tests äh haben halt weiß ich nicht ein Prozent oder einen
in der Größenordnung sind ja falsch positiv und äh wir haben ja überhaupt
nur eine positiven Rate von ein Prozent und wenn jetzt aber ein halbes Prozent äh davon falsch positive Tests sind, dann sind die Zahlen in Wirklichkeit nur halb so hoch oder je nachdem, also das sagen angezweifelt wurde
dass die Zahlen wirklich so hoch sind, sondern gesagt wurde, gut, vielleicht haben wir sogar nur ein Zehntel oder vielleicht oder einigermaßen sogar gesagt, das sind
alles äh äh jetzt nur falsch positive äh Tests. So
und da kann man aber sagen, man.
Es gibt keine gut, es gibt bei jedem zu jedem Test äh gibt es halt,
Zahlen, äh, die, die Spezifizität angeben, also wie viel falsch positive
Test, sie liegen dann so typischerweise, weiß ich nicht bei neunundneunzig Komma drei neunundneunzig Komma sechs Prozent irgendwo in der Ecke, so
Woraus jetzt viele Leute schließen, aha, dann müssen diese Tests, also.
Jetzt weiß ich nicht null Komma drei oder null Komma sechs Prozent oder so sind dann definitiv falsch positiv
äh dem ist definitiv nicht so, weil wenn man sich dann nämlich anguckt, wie die Tests durchgeführt wurden
damit die sagen an den Test das Ganze dranschreiben können. Ähm stellt man fest, dass da halt
drei oder vierhundert, fünfhundert Tests, Größenordnungsmäßig gemacht wurden, ja um.
Den Test selber zu validieren und
diese dann null Komma drei oder null Komma sechs Prozent äh kommen einfach erstmal daher, dass man gar nicht so viele, ich meine
hat jetzt nicht zehntausend Tests gemacht oder zwanzigtausend oder fünfzigtausend, um auf diese Zahlen zu kommen, sondern eben nur drei oder vierhundert und bei diesen
Fällen sind halt keine hatte man halt überall bei den Tests null falsch positive, das heißt
diese Werte, diese Angaben sind eher eine als Untergrenze zu verstehen für die Spezialität, das heißt tatsächlich
gab's dann Fälle, wo man so zwanzig, dreißigtausend Leute durchgetestet hat und dann ein oder zwei Fälle
nur hatte, die dann aber tatsächlich auch positiv,
das heißt, es war noch nicht mal falsch Positive, das heißt, wir haben
zumindest auch einzelne Fälle, wo wir sagen können, dass definitiv unter zwanzig oder dreißigtausend Tests
wir keine falsch positiven gefunden haben. Es gab dann einmal wiederum.
Wohl auch Tests, die gemacht wurden, wo dann Proben verschick
wurden einfach an Labore ohne dass die Labore das Wussten, dass das jetzt ein Test war und äh,
Da hat man dann auch versucht sozusagen einen Serva zu machen, äh wie gut sind die Labore denn in der Praxis äh jetzt
eigentlich. Und den habe ich mir jetzt nicht genau angeguckt, da kam aber auch äh irgendwie.
Zahlen raus von um die, ja, ein halbes bis anderthalb Prozent äh bei falsch
positiven äh Tests
aber das kann halt sehr, sehr stark variieren, das kann halt dann sein, dass es irgendwie aus einem Labor äh kommt, was halt misst
gemacht hat, während alle anderen richtig äh gearbeitet äh haben. So müsste man sich noch ein bisschen genauer angucken, aber.
Man kann halt auch einfach definitiv so den Menschenverstand viele Fälle zeigen, dass
ist definitiv nicht so ist, dass die Zahlen massiv verzerrt sind durch falsch positive, auch wenn man nicht genau weiß wie viele dabei sind
würde ich sagen, wenn's fünf oder zehn Prozent
sind von denen, die wir, die wir sehen, von den Zahlen, dann wäre das nach mein Gefühl oder meiner Wahrnehmung schon hoch. Also mein Wissens- und Er,
Missstand ist der, dass äh falsch positive Tests
ähm keine signifikante Auswirkung in Deutschland äh haben, auf die, auf die Zahlen, die die in Frage steht, da gibt's andere Effekte, die eben viel, viel stärker sind
so wie die Verdoppelung der Tests, ja die faktisch in einem Monat stattgefunden hat, beeinflusst die Zahlen viel stärker oder ähm,
Änderung des Testregimes oder äh verschiedene Wochen die Wochentagsschwankungen und.
Und was da halt alles noch dazu kommt. So das war sagen das das eine Ding.
Etwas in dem Zusammenhang vielleicht auch noch, äh, weil ich das ganz interessant fand, weil jemand im März hatte schon jemand rausgefunden, dass eine der
Testsequenzen von der WHO, einer der,
für den Test eine der Gensequenzen äh auch im menschlichen Genom vorkommt
so, dass da jemand rausgeschossen hat, ah äh ich meine, dann wenn diese Gensequenz nicht nur im Virus, sondern auch im menschlichen Genom vorkommt, dann ja, die Tests.
Ja auch Quatsch. So, dann kann das ja nicht funktionieren. So äh der Punkt ist nur
Also erstens ist es nicht die einzige Sequenz und in vielen Tests ist diese Sequenz kommt dort auch gar nicht vor aber selbst in Tests die diese Sequenz benutzen ist es so, dass der Kurvetest
eine sogenannte RT
PC Riss und das RT steht für reverse Transkriptase, das heißt, der testet auf RNA, das heißt die PCR ist eigentlich ein DNA-Test
ähm.
So und wenn du halt RNA damit detektieren willst, musst du halt einmal das durch einen Enzym schieben und im Prinzip in einen DNA strangen umwandeln, der dann halt verstärkt äh wird. So
aber,
Der Punkt ist für eine bei einer RT PCR, äh was als erstes gemacht wird, ist halt eine Reinigung, das heißt, da wird sämtliche DNA, wird halt entfernt aus der Probe, die da sein könnte.
Äh sodass halt selbst wenn halt diese Sequenz im menschlichen Genom äh äh erstmal vorhanden ist, äh würde dieser Test auch nicht auf
irgendwie Sachen, die in der DNA sind, ansprechen. Das Einzige, was natürlich in der Zelle wiederum stattfindet, ist, dass ja damit mit der DNA gearbeitet werden kann, äh wird das Ganze dann auch in RNA umgeschrieben, so temporär
aber dazu müsste dann halt in den Zellen nennenswert viel
von ausgerechnet diesem Genabschnitt äh dann als RNA rumlungern und das tut's offenbar nicht, weil sonst hätte man die Tests natürlich nie validieren können. Aber ich fand das auch nochmal so eine ganz interessante äh
Erkenntnis äh so wie denn im Detail jetzt diese Tests tatsächlich ablaufen und was die denn jetzt eigentlich amplifizieren,
äh Anzeigen und was nicht. Ja.
Ja das bringt mich zum letzten Test äh Punkt,
nämlich, dass ich jetzt selber äh Testbedarf habe.
Gedenke mich morgen und nächste Woche gleich zweimal testen zu lassen
keine Symptome, keine Warnung der Corona Warnapp, nichts dergleichen. Es ist eigentlich alles gut. Nur,
Ich äh versuche ja meine Podcastingtätigkeit nach alter Fassung auch wieder aufzunehmen und ähm.
Das bedeutet auch, dass ich halt wieder in so Interviewsituationen.
Also mit anderen Worten in einem Raum in einem geschlossenen Raum, der vielleicht nicht so gut durchlüftet ist über einen längeren Zeitraum äh in in unmittelbarer Nähe zu Personen.
Also, ich werde natürlich versuchen, das gleich vorwegzustellen, irgendwie.
Das draußen zu machen, sobald es möglich ist, beziehungsweise zumindest in gut durchlüfteten Situationen, beziehungsweise auch nennenswerten Abstand, ja? Das für mich
kein Problem, sie arbeitet mit Headsets und habe irgendwie immer zehn Meter äh Verlängerungskabel dabei und so weiter. Also ich muss jetzt nicht unbedingt unmittelbar bei jemandem sitzen, aber solche Gespräche ähm lassen sich.
Aus meiner Warte eben so Remote nicht so ohne weiteres replizieren. Also ich habe jetzt die Erfahrung ja auch gemacht. Das geht schon mit ein paar Leuten, die so ein bisschen erfahren sind oder wie wir das ja jetzt hier im Prinzip schon die ganze Zeit äh äh machen, wenn man sich halt kennt, aber einfach um.
Intensiv in so ein Gespräch reinzugehen mit jemanden, den man eben noch nicht kennt oder der mich vor allem nicht kennt, hm ja, ist das denn sozusagen erstrebenswert.
Jetzt habe ich eben äh es auch mal mit älteren Leuten zu tun.
Ich sage mal, erfahrenen Leuten teilweise eben sehr erfahrenen, also sprich äh äh viel Potential für äh Risiko und möchte jetzt eben diese Risikosituation auch.
Aklamation sozusagen senken. Also ich möchte gerne äh mit einem Test mit möglichst frischen Test auflaufen. Was natürlich bedeutet, ich habe erstmal keinen Grund.
Außer ich würde mich gerne mal testen lassen.
Und muss natürlich dann auch einen Ort finden, wo man das irgendwie machen kann, dass vor allem dann irgendwie auch noch aufreisen, weil natürlich dieser Test auch nur dann aussagefähig ist, wenn er irgendwie ein oder zwei Tage vorher gemacht worden ist und negativ ausfällt natürlich, ne.
Ja, jetzt werde ich aber erstmal äh durchstarten und das hier äh also ich habe dann mal so geguckt, wo kann man denn das machen? Und hier in Berlin ist es zumindest möglich, zumindest bei, also wie gesagt, ich kann nicht sagen, das ist generell so. Ich kann nur sagen, ich ich habe mich jetzt mal umgehört und,
das ist sozusagen das, was ich äh herausbekommen habe, also hier gibt's eine Hausärztin.
Um die Ecke, die haben dann immer zu definierten Uhrzeiten, machen die nur Coronate.
Also sie haben so einen Timeslot und so und dann kommt man da einfach vorbei, sagt guten Tag hier, einmal testen bitteschön.
Und dann äh geht das eben so seinen normalen äh Weg, das heißt,
Probe wird genommen, wird verschickt, geht's im Labor, wird getestet, geht wieder.
Zurück die Nachricht und erreicht mich dann, wenn die wieder arbeiten. So, das heißt, wenn ich am Freitag einen Test mache, kann ich davon ausgehen, dass ich das Ergebnis vielleicht erst am Montag habe.
Ja? Das ist dann schon nicht mehr so richtig viel wert in gewisser Hinsicht,
Weil ich ja dann schon unterwegs gewesen sein werde. Ich weiß nur, dass ich sozusagen.
Alle Leute, die nicht in den letzten zwei Tagen dann begegnet bin, von mir haben sie es nicht so, ja, also das ist sozusagen zumindest kann ich das im Nachgang sagen.
Aber ich mach's jetzt einfach trotzdem mal, weil ich das quasi bei mir jetzt so mental auch schon längst auf auf meinen Aufwand drauf gerechnet habe, ne? Also ich muss natürlich dann äh da ich keinen Anlass habe für diese Tests natürlich auch bezahlen
wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Sogar mehr. Ähm, aber ich will das halt auf jeden Fall mal einfach mal gemacht haben, weil ich das,
bisher eben noch nicht hatte. Ähm ja, haben dann eben geschaut, okay, was ist denn jetzt so unterwegs und ich komme dann irgendwie in Darmstadt vorbei, habe nochmal auf Twitter äh gefragt, so ja und dann wurde ich halt auf diese,
mobilen Tests an Flughäfen verwiesen. Darmstadt ist ja nicht weit weg vom Frankfurter Flughafen, da kann man dann schon auch mal den Schlenker machen.
Und dort gibt's ein Unternehmen, das heißt Zentrum äh Gene, die äh bieten dort eben solche Tests an, ne? Und die haben da so ein mobiles äh ähm.
Testcenter, äh also ich weiß nicht, ob sie,
Also sie werden da keine Labortechnik haben, sondern die haben sich da quasi so eine Probenentnahmestelle äh äh hingesetzt, wo man einfach äh ambulant auflaufen kann, da ist dann irgendwie Warteschlange oder nicht. Termine vergeben sie keine. Also ich muss sagen, ein bisschen Glück haben, da nicht zu lange äh zu warten.
Ähm das kann vielleicht anstrengend werden, vielleicht auch nicht, hoffe, dass ich da zum Zeitpunkt auflaufe, wo da nicht so viel los ist. Ja und dann kriegt man aber auch das Ergebnis relativ schnell, weil die natürlich nicht ohne Grund am Flughafen sind, die sind natürlich eben.
Gedacht für Leute, die eben möglichst bald dann äh verreisen wollen und garantieren eine gewisse Zeit, ne?
Und die bieten aber auch PCR-Tests für at Home an. Also du kannst dir bei Amazon irgendwie so eine Box klicken, dann kriegst du so ein Probendings zugeschickt.
Und kannst die Probe selber entnehmen, packst es dann in Tütchen ein, schickst es dahin und kriegst dann auch das Ergebnis, sobald es dann also mit einer garantierten äh Turnaroundzeit nach Eingang nach Posteingang, klar.
Kann man auch machen. Also sowas gibt's und ich werde äh dann hoffentlich in der nächsten Sendung davon berichten können, wie so meine Erfahrungen da waren.
Das ist natürlich auch so ein äh äh RT PCA Test.
Mhm. Ja, bin sehr gespannt.
Kommen wir zur Corona Warnapp, da gi,
äh erstmal eine ganze Menge Neuigkeiten und auch noch einiges nachzutragen.
Generell.
Würde ich sagen äh wenn man sich so die die Berichterstattung anschaut rund um die Corona Warn-App macht sich so ein bisschen Ernüchterung breit. Das.
Würde ich jetzt mal als normalen Medienzyklus begreifen, so, ah, da passiert ja nichts, irgendwie hat uns aber noch nicht gerettet, alles nutzlos.
Dann gab's ja diverse Aufreger mit ähm
sowohl in der App als auch im Betriebssystem. Da hat Apple ein bisschen was dazu beigetragen, weil sie diese Funktionalität mit, da kann man immer diese Fehlermeldungen hoch mit,
in deiner Region wird der Kontakt nicht unterstützt et cetera. Das waren wahrscheinlich einfach mal äh Bugs ähm,
die wahrscheinlich da reingekommen sind, weil sie eine andere Funktionalität auf die ich gleich eingehen werde.
Vorbereitet haben, die ihn so ein bisschen in die Quere gekommen ist. Na ja, ich teile diese ähm.
Stark pessimistisch getrübte Perspektive nur so begrenzt, aber ist schon klar, ne? Also das Ding hat noch nicht jetzt die Verbreitung gefunden auf der einen Seite, die vielleicht wünschenswert wäre, auch wenn's vielleicht mehr ist als.
Man so dachte, die letzten Zahlen, die veröffentlicht wurden, also wir sind stand heute, sind wir glaube ich bei siebzehn Komma acht Millionen Downloads und es gab letzte Woche noch die Meldung von der Telekom.
Die dann tatsächlich endlich mal das gemacht hat, was wir auch schon äh länger gefordert haben, nämlich einfach mal zu zählen, okay, wie viele Abfragen gibt's denn jetzt eigentlich wirklich, um mal auch eine greifbare Zahl zu bekommen.
Ähm.
Wo die App nicht nur runtergeladen wurde, sondern eben auch wirklich mal in Betrieb genommen wurde und auch im Betrieb dauerhaft ist. Und natürlich liegt diese Zahl niedriger. Das war dann vierzehn Millionen.
Gegengerechnet gegen die Anzahl der Downloads zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt läuft es auf ungefähr so achtzig einundachtzig Prozent hinaus, also ungefähr achtzig Prozent, einundachtzig Prozent der Leute, die es runtergeladen haben, betreiben diese App auch.
Beziehungsweise betreiben sie erfolgreich, ne, weil es halt auch äh die Fälle äh gab, also ähm abgesehen davon, dass es äh auch noch Bucks in der App
gab und Bax im Betriebssystem gab, die dafür versorgt haben, dass die App halt nicht regelmäßig Kies abgerufen hat. Ähm gab's das auch bei Android und bei Android ist es auch wohl teilweise immer noch so, dass
bestimmten Geräten, da ist ja einfach die Varianz, wie die Systeme gebaut sind und wie die Betriebssysteme so funktionieren, noch äh sehr viel,
größer, ja das was weiß ich, nicht genug Speicher und dann wird die App,
irgendwie nicht mehr aufgerufen und so weiter. Teilweise ist es wohl durch Backfixes
Proben wurden teilweise gibt's wohl auch einfach Geräte, die da einfach eine ganze Menge Ärger mach.
Äh damit war zu rechnen. Äh,
Ja, in der Zwischenzeit gab's ähm einige Bewegungen ähm vielleicht.
Fangen wir erstmal an mit dem, was so bisher äh passiert ist.
Es gab nämlich ähm und das ist interessanterweise relativ wenig kommentiert worden, relativ wenig diskutiert worden, so dass äh es jetzt auch ein.
Mehrere Artikel gehabt, die dann auch in der Zeit oder so irgendwie meinten, so ja äh die App funktioniert ja alles nicht und äh.
Wie soll man da Vertrauen aufbauen? Der Source Code wurde ja noch nicht mal veröffentlicht von diesem,
Fremdwork. Wo ich mir dachte so äh das hier volle sind News.
Denn und das haben wir hier aber auch noch nicht erwähnt und deswegen wollte ich das jetzt nochmal nachholen. Der Soundcode wurde veröffentlicht.
Also, was ja lange Zeit noch offen war, ob denn der Teil der quasi nicht Teil der App ist, aber auf dem Telefon läuft und sich um diese ganze Contact-Tracing äh also Kontakt ver.
Gleiche sozusagen die Kontaktüberprüfung, ähm die denen durchgeführt wird und wie diese ganzen Beakins erzeugt werden, wie die Krypto funktioniert, was wir bisher alles nur aus Spezifikationen kennen. Tatsächlich ist sowohl für iOS als auch für,
Android von Google respektive Apple, der Southgut veröffentlicht worden. Bei Google halt auf GitHub, bei.
Apple kann man sich den Soßboot so als Paket runterladen und sich dann irgendwie angucken.
Das äh finde ich soweit schon mal ganz gut, weil es zumindest.
Dieser Kritik ein wenig den Wind aus den Segeln nimmt. Ich habe jetzt nichts gesehen, wo Leute sich diesen Code genommen hätten und dann angefangen haben zu schreien, dass da irgendwas ganz furchtbares drin war. Ich weiß nicht, ob's daran liegt, dass ich das am Ende keiner wirklich angeschaut hat, das kann natürlich sehr gut sein,
oder ob da halt auch nichts drin zu finden war, weiß ich nicht. Tatsache ist, wer sich äh sowas anschauen möchte
und da mal rumgucken will, was denn damit ist, das äh gibt es auf jeden Fall alles und die passenden Links dazu natürlich in den Shownotes.
Mit einher gehen aber auch zahlreiche äh Verbesserungen. Also es gab wohl ähm abgesehen von diesen ganzen Backfixes.
Vor allem in der Android-Welt eine ganze Menge äh Verbesserung. Ähm das betrifft vor allem die Art und Weise, wie diese Bluetooth äh Vergleiche gemacht werden.
Ähm das hat äh sehr viel damit zu tun, dass,
im Gegensatz zu Apple, die ja.
Ganz genau wissen, auf welchen Geräten ihre Software läuft und natürlich auch über diese Geräte alles wissen,
Also sie wissen genau, welche Antennen sind da verbaut, was haben die für Charakteristika, et cetera, also die können diese ganze Kalibrierung mit welche Signalstärke sagt denn jetzt bei diesem Gerät eigentlich was genau aus? Äh natürlich sehr viel besser machen, weil sie halt,
alles im unmittelbaren Zugriff haben und die Experten dazu auch haben. In der Anredwelt ist es so, ja Google macht diese Software, aber die Geräte werden natürlich von.
Weiß nicht, wie viele unterschiedliche Telefonhersteller, die heutzutage an Telefone so bauen und verkaufen. Es gibt weiß ich nicht, aber es sind viele.
Und es gibt tausende von Modellen auf jeden Fall.
Gibt tausende von Modellen und mich hatte vor einiger Zeit auch schon mal jemand kontaktiert, äh die hier an der TU äh entsprechende Kalibrierungsmaßnahmen vorgenommen haben.
Und das dann mal selber mal durchgetestet haben und auch äh an Google weitergeleitet haben. Das hat wohl auch äh dort Freunde äh gefunden und tatsächlich,
ist es eben auch so, dass in diesen letzten Releases des Frameworks ist Bosa Notification Frameworks auf Android,
eben sehr viele so Kalibrierungstabellen Einzug gehalten haben. Das heißt auch Google, teilweise auch durch so eine Crautshourcing Initiative.
Äh misst quasi mehr und mehr der existierenden, realen Telefone durch äh und,
bringt quasi Parameter dort mit in ihre Releases mit rein, die dann eben für die jeweiligen Telefone das irgendwie geraderücken und alles irgendwie auch so einen einheitlichen Wert äh stellen. Das äh.
Ist ja schon mal ganz gut, ne?
Und es gab natürlich auch einige äh Verbesserungen ähm also das habe ich jetzt im Detail
nicht so hundertprozentig äh verstanden, beziehungsweise nachgelesen, aber es läuft auf sowas hinaus, dass ähm genauere Abfragen möglich sein sollen, dass äh mehr Abfragen möglich sind, dass sie bei,
teilweise glaube ich auch diese Redlimits ein bisschen runtergesetzt haben.
Also dass man äh öfter da sozusagen äh nachfragen kann, beziehungsweise, dass man genauere Informationen darüber enthält, wie diese Kontaktüberprüfung stattgefunden haben. Das kann ich jetzt im Detail alles nicht so ähm wiedergeben, aber
Underthe Hood immer noch im Rahmen der ursprünglichen Spezifikation haben sich also dort auch
Dinge äh bewegt und generell hatte ich so den Eindruck, dass ohne dass da jetzt viel drüber berichtet worden ist.
Doch eine ganze Menge hinter den Kulissen passiert.
Trotzdem war dann am Ende so die Menge an Änderungen, die so bekannt wurden.
Gesamt noch überschaubar.
Bis ähm ja,
jetzt vor kurzem
ein neues Release gemacht wurde und wie immer bin ich jetzt auf der Anrudseite da nicht Versionsnummern äh fest. Ich mach's mal an äh Apple äh Fest, weil die ja eigentlich mit Google zusammen immer relativ koordiniert diese Releases machen. Also wenn
Apple irgendwie eine Änderung im äh Expoja Notification Framework äh vornimmt, die jetzt signifikant ist, dann äh,
ist es immer Hand in Hand mit Google, also die gehen da total zeitlich getaktet vor. Und jetzt gab's vor zwei Tagen,
iOS dreizehn Punkt sieben, ein Release für die iPhones und ja da sind dann doch äh größere Änderungen auf einmal.
Drin gewesen. Und das bezieht sich im Prinzip auf zwei Dinge. Das erste ist, dass die.
Vorbereitung oder die notwendige Erweiterung jetzt drin ist, u,
dieses Roaming zu ermöglichen. Darüber haben wir hier auch schon mehrfach gesprochen.
Und es gab ja verschiedene Modelle, wie man das jetzt äh konkret macht, die so im Raum sind. Ich habe so den Eindruck, intern dürfte sich da Apple so ein bisschen durchgesetzt haben mit ihren Vorstellungen. Denn wie es jetzt läuft, ist äh
wie folgt. Also,
Zunächst einmal nochmal zu dem Problem, solange wir uns innerhalb von Deutschland bewegen und mit Deutschen, die in Deutschland sich auch bewegen, zusammentreffen, ist klar.
Alle die diese App benutzen, laden ihre Kies im Zweifelsfall, wenn sie positiv sind auf einen Server hoch und alle Apps laden's von diesem Server wieder runter und deswegen befindet man sich sozusagen in so einem gemeinsamen Datenraum.
Wenn ich aber jetzt nach Italien fahre
und dort Kontakt äh habe zu jemanden, der sich in Italien dann mit der italienischen App positiv meldet und ich fahre halt wieder zurück, dann kriege ich davon nix mit, weil dieser Key eben nicht auf dem deutschen Server landet.
Und jetzt wurde ja lange darüber diskutiert, wie wie man das löst. Und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, sieht die Lösung folgendermaßen aus. Die Telefone sind jetzt mit den neuesten Versionen in der Lage festzustellen,
ich, dass ich im Ausland war. Und die Telefone merken sich, A.
Dass ich im Ausland war und B in welchem Ausland ich war. Das heißt, das Telefon weiß, ich war an dem Tag in Italien.
Oder am nächsten Tag war ich vielleicht wieder zurück. So, wenn ich jetzt positiv getestet werde.
Und dieser Italientag fällt in diesen vierzehn Tage Zeitraum. Und ich veröffentliche meine Schlüssel, dann wird den Schlüssel.
An den betreffenden Tagen, wo ich im Ausland war, so einen Fleck hinzugefügt mit war im Ausland.
Steht nicht drin, war in Italien. Sondern da steht nur drin, war im Ausland.
Und das hat jetzt sozusagen zwei äh Folgen. Erstens ist es so, dass wenn ich den meine Schlüssel jetzt hochlade und da ist halt dieser.
Auslandsschlüssel nenne ich den jetzt mal. Dann landet der dann nicht nur auf diesem deutschen Server der Corona Warn-App.
Sondern kann eben auch noch auf einen internationalen Server hochgeladen werden.
Das wird in Europa zunächst einmal in dem ersten Schritt ein EU-Server sein.
Oder vielleicht ist es auch EU Plus X ist auf jeden Fall von der Europäischen Union, wurde interessanterweise nämlich SAP und die Telekom damit beauftragt diese Lösung jetzt für Europa bereitzustellen. Daran wird gearbeitet.
Sprich, wir werden in naher Zukunft kann ich nicht sagen, ob das jetzt in der nächsten Woche schon soweit ist oder,
nochmal ein bisschen dauert, werden wir sehen, dass es sozusagen zwei Server gibt.
Und wenn ich diesen Key halt hochlade, hier ich war positiv und ich war an dem Tag war ich in Italien kriegte eben dieses Fleck und dann geht dieser Key,
Nicht auf den deutschen Server, sondern der geht dann auf diesen Romisser oder vielleicht wieder auf beide weiß nicht ganz genau. Auf jeden Fall landet er auch bei diesem EU-Server. Jemand in Italien,
der wir jetzt mit mir vielleicht Kontakt gehabt hat kann dann einfach diesen Key von diesem Roaming-Server, von diesem EU-Server runterladen.
Und hat dann sozusagen den gleichen Service wie vorher auch.
Jetzt gibt's natürlich noch den umgedrehten Fall. Ich war in Italien, jemand in Italien wird positiv. Wie komme ich denn jetzt an dessen Kie dran? Weil.
Der war ja nicht in Deutschland, der liegt ja sozusagen nur auf seinen italienischen Server. Jetzt ist es so, dass meine App quasi die Information erhält, dass eben an einem Tag ich im Ausland war.
Und dann wird eben für diesen Tag äh auch noch der italienische nationale Server.
Abgefragt. Das heißt, es wird jetzt in zunehmenden Maße ein Wissen darüber geben, welche Server sind für welches Land zuständig, sodass die App quasi äh selber nachschauen kann.
Auch hier verlässt diese Information nicht
Telefon, ja? Also es wird nicht irgendeinem Server gesagt, ich war da, sondern es ist nur so, dass meine App dann eben für die betreffenden Tage auch noch
den italienischen Server sich die Kies dort runterlädt und da ja mehr oder weniger genauso anonym oder nicht anonym ist,
Klar, IP-Adresse und so weiter, ja? Also.
Die App weiß zumindest von wo sie sich einen Key holen soll für die betreffenden Tage.
Und das ist eigentlich schon das ganze Modell. Und das ist jetzt in dreizehn sieben in diesem Release äh mit drin. Reisestatus,
nennt sich das
Das bedeutet aber auch, dass bevor das funktioniert muss Aden natürlich dieser Roming-Server drin sein, B muss quasi auch dieses Verzeichnis geben, mit welcher Server ist denn jetzt für welches Land zuständig und natürlich müssen die Apps entsprechend angepasst werden. Also es muss auf jeden Fall erstmal noch ein
Release der Corona Warn-App geben und natürlich auch alle anderen Apps in Italien und so weiter, also alle, die an diesem System teilnehmen bevor das eben dann stattfinden kann,
Sprich, das wird noch ein bisschen dauern.
Keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt noch lange dauert oder ob das ein Prozess ist, der im nächsten Monat äh stattfindet, weil wir haben ja immer noch so ein bisschen dieses Problem.
Dass wir eben jetzt viele Köche haben. Und eigentlich viele Länder,
ihrer eigenen App mehr oder weniger alle dasselbe tun.
In unterschiedlichen äh Codebasen. Ja und große Überraschung.
Es gibt noch eine weitere Neuerung und das bezieht sich auf etwas,
was wir hier auch schon vor längerer Zeit mal diskutiert haben, nämlich so diese Ankündigung von Google und Apple, die ja am Anfang mal gesagt haben, so, na ja, unser Exposé Notification Freiburg, das kommt jetzt bald mal raus und dann kann's dafür Apps geben.
So ist es ja auch gekommen.
Und irgendwann später werden wir das ins System einbauen. Und da haben wir ja hier auch, glaube ich, relativ lange darüber gerätselt und diskutiert, was denn das jetzt eigentlich bedeuten kann.
Und eine meiner Vermutungen war und soweit ich mich jetzt äh äh daran äh zu erinnern meine, so in meiner äh Selbstüberschätzung glaube ich, dass,
in etwa so beschrieben zu haben, das Problem, dass einfach diese Leistung so eine App zu schreiben, zu Maintainen hochzuladen.
Poemira reinzusetzen und da so und so viel Millionen Euro drauf zu werfen,
Für manche Länder wahrscheinlich zu stemmen ist, aber es gibt einfach auch viele Länder gerade Afrika und so weiter, also die ganzen Entwicklungsländer, die die das so nicht leisten
können wollen und irgendwie halt auch nicht unbedingt müssten. Weil was diese App zu tun hat, ist eigentlich relativ klar.
Und jetzt gibt es halt etwas, das heißt Exposé Notifications Express. Interessantes Wording.
Und das ist im Prinzip äh Corona Warnapp, ohne Corona-Warn-App.
Angenommen, wir hätten jetzt sozusagen in Deutschland diese App nicht.
Könnte das Telefon die Aufgabe dieser App selbst vornehmen. Tatsächlich ist es wohl so auf Android wird vom Betriebssystem sogar so eine App erzeugt.
Habe ich jetzt noch nicht gesehen, aber das das ist sozusagen äh das, was in den Ankündigungen drinsteht, dass sie quasi so eine.
So 'ne generische App im System haben, die äh dann eben,
sich im Wesentlichen so verhält wie so eine, also so die wesentlichen Funktionalitäten macht, sprich holt die Kies,
oder lädt sie eben hoch und hat in irgendeiner Form ein ein Verification äh Server, so ähnlich wie das halt hier in Deutschland äh auch ist und ein Keyserver, der das eben äh verbreitet, der für das jeweilige Land zuständig ist.
Aber diese App Funktionalität auf dem Telefon wird quasi schon vom Betriebssystem
mitgeliefert, so wie du da einen Webbrowser hast und so wie du da irgendwie eine eine App hast, zum Musik abspielen, hast du halt jetzt auch eine App zum Kies hochladen und runterladen und irgendwie,
Corona-Status verwalten.
Da habe ich mich gefragt worden, dass deutete sich sozusagen schon äh an und ich dachte mir so, hm, okay, also die App
Klar, die könnt ihr ja machen, aber die Hauptaufgabe ist ja eigentlich eine andere, weil man braucht ja dann auch A
ein Server, der eben diese Kies zum Download anbietet und man braucht vor allem auch einen der diesen Test verifiziert.
Ja, also muss ja nach wie vor diese Submission deiner Keys,
kann ja nicht einfach jeder irgendwie was hochladen, weil dann funktioniert das System nicht, sondern du brauchst eben diese Verifikation.
Ja, stellt sich raus, es gibt jetzt und das hat äh so wie ich das sehe, Google gehackt. Referenzimplementierung von äh Google, zweierlei Art, nämlich einen sogenannten Testverification-Server und einen Keyserver.
Das ist Kot, den kannst du dir runterladen und kannst du selber installieren und selber betreiben. Sprich, es gibt jetzt so eine äh ja, wie sagt man, so eine äh.
Fertige Lösung, nee, wie sagt man? Schlüsselfert.
Schlüssel fertig.
Genau, eine schlüsselfertige äh Lösung. Wenn du also jetzt Land X bist, die äh keinen Bock haben, das irgendwie alles selber zu entwickeln,
du dir den Testverification-Server und den Keyserver von Google runterladen, der ist irgendwie auf Gitter irgendwo rum.
Wirfst ihn auf irgendeine Infrastruktur? Das dürfte wahrscheinlich nicht besonders schwierig sein. Ich meine, wenn.
Google irgendwas kann, dann können sie irgendwie so Server Infrastruktur, ja, das kriegst du also schon irgendwie Deployd und es gibt ausführliche Dokumentationen, wie du die dann eben zu konfigurieren hast.
Weil natürlich diese Server einerseits natürlich wiederum eine Anbindung haben müssen an irgendein System für diese Überprüfung, wie wir das hier in Deutschland zum Beispiel haben, entweder mit diesem QR-Code oder mit dieser Teletan, also das ist sozusagen eine explizite
kunft
des Gesundheits, der Gesundheitsämter äh äh gibt oder beziehungsweise die Anbindung an diese Labore, wo eben ein Test, der stattgefunden hat, eben verifiziert wird, wo dieser App dann gesagt wird, so, ja, okay, so funktioniert das auch.
Das war jetzt ein positiver Test. Diese Person darf von ihrem Telefon jetzt auch diese Kies entsprechend auf unseren Kiesherber hochladen.
Und im Wesentlichen funktioniert das alles so ähnlich wie das die Corona Barnap auch implementiert hat,
so auf den ersten Blick sehe ich nur einen Unterschied. Äh es gibt bei der,
CWA-Lösung noch eine Kommunikation zwischen diesem Keysurver und dem Verification Server, wenn ich meine Kies hochlade
die ich von diesem Verification-Server bekommen habe,
hat die quasi dem Kieser hoch und sagt, hier ist meine Tarn und dann gibt's noch so eine Rückfrage von dem Keyserver zum Verification-Server, ob denn diese Taten auch stimmt.
Bei der Google-Lösung, wie es nicht anders zu erwarten war, wird das mit Zertifikaten gemacht, also da gibt's sozusagen so eine Kryptochain, das heißt dieser
Verification-Server hat ein Zertifikat, unterschreibt dann quasi diese Tarnkryptographisch, sodass in dem Moment, wo ich meine Keys mit diesem Zertifikat, auf den Keysurver hochlade, der eben nicht mehr mit dem anderen Server überhaupt noch kommunizieren muss, sondern da steht einfach drin, ja, hier Zertifikat, kryptografisch unterschrieben, passt schon, der darf das
so. Und dann geht's los. So und das ist die Situation, in der wir uns jetzt.
Hm vielleicht,
eins äh äh hast du wahrscheinlich dann vergessen, zu erwähnen, was dann aber noch passieren muss oder was jemand äh da machen muss, ist dann entweder von Google oder von Apple oder wer auch immer, dann sagen der Betreiber
von dem von dem Ganzen ist, der muss entsprechende äh äh Zertifikate oder Signaturen äh bereitstellen oder ein Zertifikat signieren
von den Betreibern, äh, damit die sozusagen autorisiert sind, weil sonst könnte ja jetzt jeder daherkommen, die Software ausgetappt, runterladen und selber irgendwie so ein Verification-Dingens betreiben, äh ja.
Klar, dass das äh versteht sich natürlich von selbst, ich mein das ist ja jetzt auch jetzt schon so, ne? Es gibt halt einfach pro Region, gibt es eben eine einzige Behörde, die das entscheiden darf, nämlich die Health of Hority, also in unserem Falle eben RKI und in anderen Ländern eben äh eine andere Infrastruk
also jedes Land
meldet sich quasi bei äh Apple und Google oder in dem Fall vielleicht sogar nur bei Google, ich weiß nicht genau, wer das dann macht und sagt so, hallo, wir sind hier doller Land. Wir würden jetzt gerne mal diesen Server äh,
anmelden. Wir haben das jetzt hier aufgesetzt, wir haben das Ding konfiguriert, wir haben da unsere Bewertungskriterien
mit reingebracht, ne? Also diese ganzen Parameter, die ja dann auch immer noch mit übertragen werden, damit die Apps auch wissen, was sie tun sollen. Aber
Sie müssen eben auch nicht sehr viel mehr machen als das.
Sie nehmen sich die Software, sie installieren das Ding, dann läuft das auf einer Infrastruktur, die dann äh die entsprechende Netzwerkanbindung hat und die Leute in dem Land auch
ordentlich zu bedienen.
Sie lassen sich dann ihre Zertifikate vermutlich entweder bestätigen oder ausstellen oder melden die oder kriegen die von Google weiß ich nicht ganz genau wie das läuft, habe ich mir jetzt nicht durchgelesen und dann sind die eben auch gemeldet und dann wissen eben auch die Apps
Wer ist der Server oder wer sind die beiden Server für das jeweilige Land, damit eben auch diese Roaming-Geschichte dann,
Darüber auch automatisch funktionieren kann. Aber du musst halt nicht selber proamieren. Du nimmst einfach den Server, wie er von Google kommt.
Betreibst den, konfigurierst den? Das ist deine Aufgabe, Administration und Konfiguration.
Aber du musst keine App machen, du musst kein keinen Servercode entwickeln, du musst ja irgendwie über die Krypto und die ganze Sicherheit von dem ganzen Kram keinen Gedanken machen, weil es gibt einfach genau eine Referenzimplementierung und die funktioniert einfach.
Und ja, ich kann nur sagen, Tokyo Soul, also das ist jetzt genauso gekommen, wie ich mir das mal äh gedacht habe und tatsächlich.
Wird es dazu führen, nehme ich an.
Also jetzt ist auf jeden Fall die Schwelle an so einem System teilzunehmen, sehr viel niedriger geworden. Du musst jetzt überhaupt gar keine Softwareentwicklung mehr betreiben.
Sondern du kannst einfach sagen als Land,
Hallo, wir wollen jetzt gerne hier äh das auch auf die ganzen Smartphones machen mit einem aktuellen Betriebssystem Updates, sind alle Telefone
in der Lage an diesem System teilzunehmen, alles was es noch braucht sind diese beiden Server, die müssen konfiguriert,
angemeldet, verifiziert sein und dann kann's losgehen und dann wissen Google und Apple A, alles klar, diese Region ist jetzt auch mitversorgt. Und wenn ich dann halt in dieses Land fahre und da eben.
War, weiß meine Corona Warn-App dann auch schon wieder von welchem Server sie das holen soll, ne.
Das heißt, die Kroner Warnapp muss natürlich jetzt auch auf dieses Protokoll umgestellt werden.
Also sie muss sozusagen auch diesen anderen Submission Weg,
auch unterstützen. Das wird wahrscheinlich ein bisschen dauern, aber da ist auf jeden Fall jetzt Arbeit zu leisten, aber es gibt dann sozusagen ein,
ein Standard und ich wäre jetzt auch nicht überrascht, wenn sie dann halt mittelfristig äh vielleicht auch auf diesen Keysurver und diesen Verification-Server umstellen oder zumindest ihren eigenen äh kompatibel dazu machen.
Ja, das klingt doch eigentlich alles ganz erfreulich äh muss ich sagen, mir gefällt auch sagen diese
Roming Lösung, die europäische oder generell eigentlich die Roaming Lösung äh gefällt mir eigentlich ganz gut. Ich hatte
immer versucht, dann äh mal äh zu sehen, letztlich äh,
führt das ja dann dazu, dass praktisch, also nehmen wir mal an die App, wäre jetzt.
Überall auf der Welt würde sie genutzt, dann,
bedeutet das, dass sozusagen alle Reisenden der Welt äh äh.
Auf einen Server zugreifen.
Ja beziehungsweise ja genau auf ein,
Server äh ihre Daten hochladen und äh dann auch ja,
nee, runterladen, doch eigentlich auch alle, eigentlich müssen
dann aber was was noch viel schlimmer ist eigentlich muss ja dann jeder im Grunde genommen auch diesen Auslandsserver,
Anfragen wobei er ihn nur anfragen müsste hinsichtlich sagen wer von denen war jetzt eigentlich in meinem,
Land sehe ich das richtig.
Also wenn du im Ausland warst und du möchtest gerne Kies haben, dann ist entscheidend wo du warst und dann fragst du den nationalen Server.
Weil wenn du jetzt nach Kenia fährst und Kenia hat so einen so einen Server eingerichtet und du warst da drei Tage dann fragt,
deine deutsche App den kenianischen Server. Wenn du,
selber positiv bist, lädst du quasi das auf diesen
Jetzt im ersten Schritt wahrscheinlich erstmal auf diesen EU-Server hoch und potenziell würde ja sogar,
Server für die ganze Welt ausreichen, weil natürlich die Zahl von Leuten, die im Ausland sind.
Im Vergleich zu den Leuten, die zu Hause sind, wahrscheinlich immer extrem klein sein wird und von daher sehr händelbar sein wird.
Ja, das ist sehr interessant, das mal durchzurechnen äh oder das ist genau der der Fall, weil eigentlich um jetzt aber das Problem sagen, der
Ausländer, die jetzt hier was weiß ich, Berlin besucht haben, damit ich sagen, auch die
Warte mal näher, die Warnungen aller Ausländer würde ich ja schon
kommen, weil die, die ja dann auch einfach auf den deutschen Server auch mit hochladen, richtig?
Nein, sie laden nicht die Kiten. Nein.
Also muss ja zwei Fälle unterscheiden so. Ich war im Ausland und dort hat sich jemand positiv gemeldet. Dann muss ich mir diesen.
Ne, weil der in seinem eigenen Land bleibt, ist er auf diesen nationalen Server, aber mein Telefon weiß ja, dass ich da war und mein Telefon weiß auch, welcher Server dafür zuständig ist.
Genau, ich ich rede jetzt, ich rede jetzt zu sagen äh äh davon sagen, wie komme ich.
Als Berliner, äh, der sich in Berlin aufgehalten hat, äh, sagen Andy Kies von.
Besuchern, die hier waren, die dann äh ins Ausland zurück äh sind und dort dann positiv getestet.
Die holst du von diesem Reiseserver quasi. Du holst dir einfach alle Deutschen, Meldungen und alle internationalen Meldungen.
Genau, das war's, was ich, was ich, was ich halt meinte, dass im Prinzip jeder äh sagen, auch immer dann auf den italienischen äh äh italienischen, auf den.
Internationalen Server auch immer abrufen muss. Das heißt, du hast eigentlich immer sagen zwei Abrufe dann für jeden Tag.
Zukünftig.
Zukünftig. Gibt's einfach so einen World World Travel, Corona, Travel Server.
Oder vielleicht gibt's auch mehrere, ja, vielleicht sagt man einfach, okay, es gibt den für die EU, es gibt den für Amerika und es gibt den für Asien, also dass man das so kontinental gruppiert oder wie auch immer.
Ja, dann musst du natürlich fünf Server abfragen.
Ja, musst du fünf Server abfragen, aber ich meine, das ist dann auch nicht so das Ding.
Wahrscheinlich nicht ne zumal.
Ich meine, wir reden hier von so einem harte TP Rique, die machst du dann halt einfach mal, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, fertig.
Zumal wie ich das, wenn ich das richtig sehe, wird ja je ein wird ja für jeden Tag ein einzelner Rickfest ausgeführt.
Es wird nicht so sagen, es es werden jedes Mal, also sehe ich zumindest in meinen Logs, dass jeden Tag bei mir im Moment äh vierzehn Rick Fests
ausgeführt werden und ich davon ausgehe, dass das vierzehn Rique für die vierzehn zurückliegenden Tage sind, die ja da.
Macht äh gerade. Und das heißt äh ja.
Es würden dann eben entsprechend daraus würden, dann weiß ich nicht achtundzwanzig plus, wenn ich selber im Ausland war. Ja, ich überlege jetzt noch dann äh den den Fall.
Wenn ich,
im Ausland war und also wenn ich was weiß ich in Frankreich war und dort auf einen Italiener getroffen äh bin.
Dann war der Italiener auch im Ausland und seinen Kiews auf jeden Fall auch auf diesem Auslandsserver.
Und meine es auch aus dem Ausland.
Genau, also es ist sozusagen, du hast halt dann,
Versorgung wo die meisten wahrscheinlich herkommen, weil du in der Regel ja einfach mit De.
Triffst so, ne? Und äh es mag Länder geben wie Luxemburg oder so, die sagen wir mal sehr viel mehr Reiseaktivität ins Ausland haben, weil das einfach so viel Ausland drumherum gibt und so wenig Inland, so, ja,
die fallen dann aber auch nicht groß ins Gewicht, ja? Aber es ist sozusagen dein, dein,
du hast halt deinen eigenen nationalen Server und dann hast du noch diesen Catchall irgendwie alle reisenden Server und die werden sicherlich das durchgerechnet haben, was sie so meinen, wie viele Leute so international reisen im Vergleich zu Leuten, die das nicht tun. Und ich glaube, diese Zahl ist,
sehr gering. Insbesondere derzeit.
Ja
Als ich meine, wer verreist jetzt schon international? Nicht viele Leute, ne? Klar.
In Europa in gewisser Hinsicht gilt das natürlich in den USA,
äh auch, ne? Also die USA zählt da auch eher als fünfzig Staaten.
So wie ich das richtig sehe, äh wenn ich das richtig sehe, äh haben die da eine relativ klare Abgrenzung der Gesundheitszuständigkeit äh auf Staatenbas,
gibt da kein Federalsystem, das heißt das System ist an der Stelle auch für die USA schon äh relevant. Ähm aber das.
Ändert letzten Endes äh nichts, ne? Alles, was das Gesamtsystem nur wissen muss, ist, was sind sozusagen die Reiseserver für bestimmte Regionen.
Ja, also wenn ich
USA nach Illinois fahre ja so was ist der Catchall für äh alle US-Staaten, da wird's wahrscheinlich einen US-Server geben. Und dann gibt's vielleicht nochmal einen für,
Kanada und äh wie oder vielleicht gibt's auch einen für Nordamerika, das weiß ich jetzt alles nicht, ne? Äh irgendjemand wird den schon betreiben.
Ja, Corona Warnapp. Ähm was ich jetzt auch noch las, war,
dass es eine Umfrage gab, nach der jeder zweite geantwortet hat, er wolle die Corona Warnapp nicht installieren. Sagen, das ist.
Von, wo wir sagen, Corona Warnapp.
Einen Skeptikern. Ja. Corona waren im App Skeptikern äh gib.
App-Kritiker nennt man sowas heutzutage.
App Kritik.
Ja äh was ich schon etwas bedauerlich finde. Also ich hätte gedacht, so, ja gut, die fünfzig Prozent wahrscheinlich eher aus,
es ist sie einfach nicht interessiert, gut ich.
Hatte da jetzt nicht gesehen, dass das dort nach Gründen gefragt wurde, war,
müsste mir mal genauer anschauen, aber ganz unabhängig,
davon fände ich's ja ganz ganz gut vielleicht.
Mal ähm ja für diejenigen, die vielleicht,
jetzt zuhören und ein bisschen,
eigentlich überzeugt davon sind, dass es eine gute Sache ist mit der Corona Warnapp und das ähm
der äh ja Schaden oder die Gefahren in keinem Verhältnis stehen zu dem möglichen Nutzen. Da kommen wir vielleicht ja auch noch zu.
Dass wir vielleicht alle uns mal vornehmen so rauszugehen im engeren Freundes und Bekanntenkreis und da mal erstmal erstens nachzuhaken, selber so, ey, sag mal, hast du,
nutzt du eigentlich die Corona äh Warnapp und wenn nicht, dann vielleicht zu diskutieren und zu versuchen
je nachdem warum die Leute das nicht nicht wollen sie zu überzeugen das vielleicht doch
äh zu tun oder ihnen zu helfen oder ihnen das zu erklären, was denn da passiert ähm dass
denke ich äh ja, wenn man davon überzeugt ist, dass das mit der Corona-Warn-App eine gute Sache ist. Ähm
dann wäre das vielleicht eine ganz gute Maßnahme da von den fünfzig Prozent vielleicht fünf oder zehn Prozent noch zu überzeugen, äh, das doch zu tun.
Ich würde noch nicht mal sagen, dass man gleich äh soweit gehen muss, dass es dass es eine gute Sache ist. Es reicht, glaube ich, schon, wenn man die Leute überzeugt, dass es keine schlechte Sache ist. Ja, also äh äh.
Mhm. Ja, ja.
Man muss ja gar nicht so positivistisch da rangehen und sagen, ja, das wird auf jeden Fall hier irgendwie Corona stoppen, sondern das ist halt eher so dieses so, ja, kann sein, kann nicht sein, aber es schadet auf jeden Fall nichts daran teilzunehmen und wenn irgendwas äh passieren soll, dann hängt es eben genau davon ab,
Ich hatte jetzt auch gerade so eine äh äh Runde so,
typische Elternabend äh äh Runde, wo dann auch die Frage äh rumging und ich glaube von sechs, sieben Leuten äh.
Eine Person hat es nicht installiert, aber nicht jetzt unbedingt aus.
Bewussten Ablehnung, sondern eher so ein ja ähm weiß nicht, noch nicht zugekommen, die Gedanken darüber gemacht, also wo du genau.
Ne, wo man äh sozusagen wo ich glaube ich dann in dem Moment auch in der Runde, äh, weil alle anderen so, ja klar, äh, gesagt haben, ne? Und dann äh eine weitere Person meinte, ja, mein Telefon kann das nicht.
So, weil es halt.
Immer noch Leute gibt, die dann halt mit sehr alten Telefonen rumlaufen und für sich jetzt irgendwie,
nicht sehen, dass sie das in eine neue Generation überführen wollen, aber das ist halt etwas, das spült sich jetzt von alleine raus. Also das,
ne, es werden permanent neue Telefone gekauft, irgendwann sind sie,
irgendwann sind sie dann doch zu langsam, irgendwann hat man doch mal das Geld zusammen. Also,
Klar, das ist ein gewisser Anteil, aber der macht's nicht aus. Also das sind nicht die
die zwanzig Prozent, die äh Differenz dazu Download-Zahl machen und das sind auch nicht die achtzig Prozent, die uns jetzt noch fehlen, ne? Also derzeit haben wir halt ungefähr zwanzig Prozent Verbreitung.
Ähm gut, jetzt wird's im Zweifelsfall noch mehr werden. Und ich denke, viel hängt auch davon ab.
Wie sich das jetzt weiterentwickelt, weil das hatten wir ja glaube ich auch schon gesagt, dass hier eigentlich relativ wenig.
Bass drumrum war, ne? War viel hype am Anfang, dann kam sie endlich raus, dann haben wir uns alle gefreut, hurra, hurra, hurra, jetzt haben wir die Corona Warn App und dann so next irgendwie nächstes Thema, jetzt machen wir erstmal Sommerferien. Und jetzt kommt das eigentlich erst langsam wieder auf den Tisch.
Es gibt in diesem Zusammenhang einen interessanten Artikel, der auch äh bei Zeit online erschienen ist, den äh.
Gemeinsam von Henning Tillmann und Karl Lauterbach geschrieben wurde. Henning Tillmann ist auch so Informatiker, beschäftigt sich auch exzensiv mit dieser Corona-Warne von Anfang an, hat also äh Einblick,
hat sich das auch sehr genau angeschaut, selber auch äh Entwickler und äh Karl Lauterbach von der SPD, der,
Gesundheits, ich weiß nicht, selbst gesundheitspolitischer Sprecher eigentlich für die SPD, weiß ich auf jeden Fall, ist seit dieser ganzen Debatte sehr engagiert, schon seit Längerem und hat da auch medizinische Expertise, ist glaube ich selber Arz.
Werner sogar einschlägig, der hat äh irgendwie äh äh genau irgendwie Epidemiologie. Äh ah ich glaube, er ist sogar Epidemiologe äh ja und warte mal ein Institut geleitet. Äh also ist.
Mal gerade nach. Politiker, Mediziner, Gesundheitsökonomen. Mhm.
Okay. Ja, also das Thema steht ihm auf jeden Fall nahe. Äh deswegen äh ist er halt äh genau. Ich bin der Epidemologin verheiratet. Das könnte helfen.
Aber nicht nur ja, nee, nicht nur das, sondern äh.
Humanmedizin hat er studiert und ist Doktor Med. Also der steckt im Thema. So und Gesundheitsökonomie hat er auch noch studiert. Also.
Auf jeden Fall die beiden haben so einen Artikel äh rausgebracht ähm auf Zeit,
online, wo sie so vier Vorschläge gemacht haben, wie man die Corona-Warn-App verbessern kann. Und das geht im Wesentlichen
in diese Diskussion rein, die wir anfangs schon angedeutet hatten mit den Ariosolen und dass wir jetzt so sehr viel mehr Wissen darüber, wie die Verbreitungswege eigentlich sind, weil diese
Funktionalität der Corona Warn App basiert ja im Prinzip immer noch auf dieser Annahme zwei Meter Abstand,
Das ist das, was eingehalten werden muss. Und wenn jemand weiter weg ist, dann,
ist es kein Risiko. So, aber wir wissen natürlich jetzt,
einerseits.
Dass das durchaus ein Risiko ist. Äh auch wenn eben anderer Abstand ist, da kann man einfach mal drüber debattieren, ob man diese jetzt schon vorhandenen Parameter vielleicht auch mal anders einstellt, dass man vielleicht sagt.
Nehmen wir mal ein anderes.
Einen anderen Cut auf bei den Bluetooth äh Signalen gehen von anderen Distanzen aus, kann man machen, kann man auch nicht machen. Ja? Oder äh macht man eben die App auch auf eine andere Art und Weise fit.
Für die neuen Erkenntnisse, die ja im Wesentlichen auch sich auf diese ganze Clusterproblematik äh konzentrieren. Das heißt.
Die Erkenntnis, dass die Ausbreitung des Virus im Wesentlichen durch Cluster getrieben wird.
Die soll er quasi mit einfließen. Na ja, was haben sie jetzt äh vorgeschlagen,
Erstmal erster Punkt, hier heißt mehr Information, mehr Transparenz und da haben sie im Wesentlichen beklagt, dass wir in dem Moment, wo man jetzt so einen Kontakt hatte, dass einem die App, also konkret die Corona-Warn-App derzeit ja noch nicht mal sagt, an welchem Tag das der Fall war,
Und das wusste ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht oder habe ich vielleicht überlesen? Ähm weil.
Ich hätte ja jetzt sozusagen noch keine keine Warnung, von daher weiß ich auch nicht, was äh gesagt wird, aber das stimmt schon.
Es wird einem halt einfach relativ wenig Detail gegeben. Kann man sich fragen, ja warum? Ja, Datenschutz, mhm. Aber das ist eine Information, die von diesem Exposion Notification Framework.
Mitgeliefert wird. Also in dem Moment, wo ich diese Kontaktüberprüfung mache, also wo die App, diese Kontaktüberprüfung macht, also sich frische Kies runterlädt und den Betriebsdienst sagt, so hier, guck mal, neue Kies haben wir einen von denen gesehen, dann macht die Überprüfung und sagt so, ja, habe ich gesehen.
Aber Parameter haben nicht gereicht oder habe ich gesehen und die Parameter sagen ist ein Risiko. In dem Fall erhält man das Datum.
Das Framework-Kenn-Datum und Uhrzeit, aber ich glaube, es wird nur das Datum weitergeleitet, aber nicht mal dieses Datum schafft es bis zum User.
Und das könnte einem natürlich schon dabei helfen, weil wenn man weiß, an dem Tag so, ah, da war ich auf der großen Konferenz und so weiter, mit ganz vielen Leuten.
Darauf wollen sie sozusagen äh auch hin, ne? Dann ist das ja schon mal eine wertvolle Information. Also, dass man einfach mehr Informationen mitgibt, da gehe ich auch mit, ne? Und zweiter Vorschlag von Ihnen ist die Clustererkennung in der Gegenwart, also.
Was sie damit meinen ist in dem Moment, wo ich mich jetzt unter vielen Leuten bewege, die alle im Idealfall natürlich diese App haben, ne? Dann.
Merkt das Telefon das natürlich. Also das Telefon sammelt ja mehr Kies ein.
Sprich, es gibt da schon ein Indikator, einen theoretischen Indikator für du bewegst dich viel unter Leuten.
Ganz unqualifiziert davon, ob diese Leute jetzt infiziert sind oder nicht,
Aber es ist natürlich eine Information, die man im Prinzip durchreichen könnte. Und an der Stelle sind wir auch schon das erste Mal an so einem Punkt, wo es eben jetzt nicht nur reicht,
die App zu ändern, sondern das ist ja quasi dann auch eine Anforderung, die man eben auch an Google und Apple stellen müsste mit hier, hör mal.
Wenn ihr sowas feststellt, warum sprecht ihr nicht eine Warnung aus? Und das.
Wäre dann halt so eine Sache mit okay, du hast heute aber viel Kontakt gehabt. So, ich habe viele Kies gesehen, du bist viel unter Leuten. Und dann könnte man halt überlegen, was man mit dieser Information macht, nehmen sie anzeigt oder ob die App sich das vielleicht selber notiert.
Den Tag als Tag mit viel Aktivität markiert, ne, dass man diese Information nachschlagen.
Ja
Also, finde ich auch ein bisschen schwammig, dann gehen sie noch ein bisschen weiter und meint, na ja, man sollte ja auch noch mal Bluetooth und WLAN-Signale mit einbeziehen
also dass man sozusagen andere Bluetooth Beakons nicht nur die von dieser von diesen Protokoll quasi auch noch mit einbezieht.
Das halte ich dann doch für sehr schwierig äh durchzusetzen, zumal WLAN, Scanning, dann ja sozusagen auch noch mit reinkommt, dann hast du halt einerseits so ein bisschen auch wieder so ein Privatsphäre äh äh Aspekt, gut, das soll natürlich nicht das Telefon verlassen
soll sozusagen nur mehr äh Wissen über ich befinde mich in einem Cluster generiert, ne? Also umso mehr digitale Aktivität um mich herum ist.
Ja? Wobei da ist es schwer zu sagen, habe ich jetzt nur viele Geräte oder habe ich viele Menschen um mich herum, ne.
Ja, ich finde auch die Clustergeschichte abgesehen davon, dass sie gesagt etwas schwammig ist ähm ich meine,
am Ende wenn ich mich in einem Cluster bewegt äh äh habe so und viele Leute tatsächlich.
Dabei hatten, dann werden halt auch viele Leute gewarnt werden, so, wenn's dann infizierten gab, so und.
Eigentlich äh ja, wenn die Leute gewarnt werden und äh sie überlegen sich testen
zu lassen und positiv getestet werden, dann wird ja das Cluster sozusagen dadurch dem Gesundheitsamt sowieso bekannt, ja? Da brauche ich jetzt nicht.
Die Warnapp, sondern als letztlich als Folge stellt dann,
irgendjemand beim Gesundheitsamt auf einmal fest, okay, da sind jetzt irgendwie haben sich jetzt drei oder fünf Leute gemeldet
die sich wahrscheinlich da und da angesteckt äh haben, ja, dann habe ich also dazu brauche ich jetzt keine Änderung an der App vorzunehmen, sondern eigentlich äh ist der Schlüssel dazu, dass möglichst viele Leute
sie installieren und betreiben.
Weil ansonsten also da die jetzt sozusagen dann mit mit Features äh weiter zu,
beladen, die zum Teil eben sogar problematisch sind, da halte ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel von.
Ja. Also hat mich, hat mich jetzt auch nicht so umgehauen. Äh klar kann man irgendwie machen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt so eine große ähm große Sprung nach vorne wäre. Dritter Punkt heißt dann Klasseererkennung in der Vergangenheit.
Also wenn man ein ähm positiven Kontakt hat und dann von diesen Clustern halt wusste, also wenn das System sozusagen selber diese Annahme hat, ich befand mich unter vielen Leuten, dass sie dann irgendwie andere Warnungen noch äh aussp
hier ist dann auch irgendwie von Push-Notifications äh äh die Rede, sowas gibt's ja derzeit bei der Corona Warnap eigentlich gar nicht. Ich
haltet das nicht für technisch durchsetz,
ja, also sie sprechen davon hier, wenn die App-Clustersituationen gut erkennen kann, wäre es auch denkbar, dass Teilnehmerinnen und Teilnehmer des Clusters per Push nur Nachricht gewarnt werden, die keinen direkten Kontakt zum infizierten gehabt haben. Das ist ja im Prinzip das Modell, was die Österreicher auch,
in ihrer App mit eingebaut haben, dass man auch so so Warnungen losschicken kann
das wird natürlich mit dem generellen Funktionsprinzip dieser ganzen Kieser et cetera so ein bisschen.
Kollidieren, die er derzeit ausschließlich von positiven Meldungen ausgeht und wo Warnung so noch gar nicht abgebildet sind.
Weiß auch nicht, ob das so viel bringen wird letztlich.
Der vierte Punkt ist der Wunsch nach einem Kontakttagebuch, dass du sozusagen die App noch so als Notizblock benutzen kannst, um irgendwie Kontakte aufzuzeichnen.
Ja, also ich glaube.
Die Intention ist so ein bisschen die Leute auch mehr mit dieser App äh interagieren lassen zu wollen, aber ehrlich gesagt ist das etwas, was wirklich normalerweise gerne tun würdest, also das ist ähm,
glaube ich am Ende ein Feature, was keiner benutzen würde und von daher würde es äh äh relativ wenig bringen. Ich habe mich ein bisschen gewundert über diese,
Vorschläge die haben also.
Der erste Punkt geht in Ordnung, ja? Also mehr Informationen anzeigen immer gut. Also wenn diese Information vor allem ohnehin schon vorliegt, ne? Und vielleicht.
Gibt's hier auch noch im Framework bestimmte Aspekte, die die generiert werden können, äh die man angezeigt bekommen möchte. Aber was mir halt jetzt total fehlt.
Jetzt kommen wir ja wieder zu diesen Ariosolen ist dass das Kernproblem derzeit eigentlich in dieser Risikoeinschätzung.
Äh ist.
Ich meine, was würdest du denn sagen, was das Hauptkriterium derzeit ist, was man was die Leute so als Risikoeinschätzung benutzen? Das ist doch einfach drinnen oder draußen.
Die App müsste eigentlich wissen, können wann befinde ich mich drin und wann befinde ich mich draußen.
Und das ist eine Information, die glaube ich, dieses Smartphones heutzutage noch nicht erzeugen, aber vielleicht hier einfach mal erzeugen sollten und die dann auch einen interessanten, neuen Parameter sozusagen mit reinbringen.
Weil natürlich die Distanz automatisch sich ändern könnte, je nachdem, ob man drinnen oder draußen ist.
Zumal, dass in den meisten Fällen, also außer vielleicht in Zelten oder in äh irgendwelchen wirklich äh ja
äh dünnen eingeschossigen Bauten oder so.
Weil äh eigentlich kannst du drin und draußen ja ganz gut daran unterscheiden, ob du ein GPS Signal äh äh empfängst oder nicht.
Genau, das wäre nämlich auch meine Idee, ne? Also die Telefone haben alle GPS, machen aber ihre Ordnung eben auch über andere äh Daten, wie zum Beispiel WLAN
wenn du aber drinnen bist, siehst du einfach nicht so viele Satelliten und das weiß das Telefon, das Telefon weiß immer.
Wie viele Satelliten es gerade sieht, also zumindest und da wird's natürlich jetzt ein bisschen schwierig.
Wenn das Betriebssystem auf diese Information auch den Zugriff hat, weil das befindet sich natürlich in der Regel in diesem Baustein drin, der von einem anderen Hersteller ist.
Also das GPS ist doch äh wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche ähm zusammen in diesem GSM Modul mit drin.
Ja, nee, normalerweise, also bei bei ich weiß gar nicht, wo Apple das genau äh äh hinbaut
ähm unter Endroid ist entweder auch einen extra äh Chip, der nichts anderes äh macht
ähm üblicherweise habe ich jetzt, also es.
Reihe von Android Modellen, wo das jetzt in die Sensor Britch mit verbaut ist, wo auch alle anderen Sensoren
drin dran angeschlossen sind sozusagen, dass ja ähm aber
aber unabhängig davon müsstest du dann halt schon zwischendurch mal das Ganze anschmeißen. Normalerweise ist es glaube ich äh ist der Empfänger äh einfach nicht unter Strom aus Stromspargründen äh äh vor allem.
Ja und vor allem die Telefone wissen auf jeden Fall, wie genau die Ortung ist, weil diese Information hast du ja auch selber, wenn du deine Map aufrufst, so, dann siehst du ja, ob dein dein Punkt genau bestimmt werden kann oder nicht genau bestimmt werden kann. Und äh das.
Hat meistens was damit zu tun äh wie gut das GPS Signal ist.
Klar, ja, aber dann äh sozusagen wird vorher immer das der GPS-Stein wird dann auch angeschmissen, ganz äh schnell und dann oft schrumpft dann halt der, sobald der lastig nahe geortet äh hat.
Schrumpft dann auch dieser Kreis und deine Position. Ich meine, was das Telefon immer hat, immer weiß, ist in welcher Funkzelle es ist. Äh aber ähm ja das.
Das sagt ja nicht viel.
Bei der unter. Das hilft bei der Unterscheidung nicht, aber auf jeden Fall, ich ich glaube, es wäre durchaus machbar, ähm so.
Alle.
Ja paar Minuten auch mal kurz äh das GPS anzuschmeißen, aber müssen wir mal durchrechnen, ob das nicht das dann doch die Bakterielaufzeit verkürzt, aber.
Die Telefone zumindest so bauen, dass das irgendwie alles äh äh geht.
Ja, aber also ist auf jeden Fall erstmal also nicht würde ich nicht von vornherein von der Hand weisen. Das ist durchaus,
ist und auch unter Wahrung der Privatsphäre, weil das könnte das äh System Framework ja quasi
alleine machen ohne jetzt dann wirklich den Ort weiter zu leiten oder den Ort zu aktualisieren, sondern einfach nur zu guck.
Wie viel Satelliten sehe ich denn jetzt gerade? Also ich überhaupt, welche.
Also was das Telefon auch weiß ständig ist äh ob es bewegt wird, dieser.
Also zumindest bei den iPhones ist ja dieser Schrittzählerchip sage ich mal äh jetzt beziehungsweise eigentlich ist es ist es ein Low Powerchip
der halt mit äh ja wenig Strom verbraucht, den Beschleunigungssensor ständig abfragt.
Und darüber dann zum Beispiel die die Schritterkennung,
macht, ob du läufst oder nicht. Das ist läuft sozusagen auch ständig immer mit und darüber kann man dann natürlich auch feststellen, so bewegt.
Sich. Außerdem ist halt auch noch ein Barometer eingebaut
auch glaube ich ständig miterfasst wird, aber auf jeden Fall äh gäb's glaube ich durchaus noch andere Möglichkeiten festzustellen. Beispiel
ob ich mich bewege oder nicht und abhängig davon, ob ich mich bewege, äh, auch noch vielleicht andere Dinge zu tun oder also bei.
Oder äh dann wenn ich mich aufhöre zu bewegen, wenn ich mich irgendwo niedergelassen habe, dann zu gucken, ob ich drin oder draußen.
Binden und äh wenn er das und dann weiß ich halt, solange ich mich nicht bewegt habe, bin ich halt weiter drin und erst wenn ich mich wieder bewege, äh muss ich dann äh wieder erneut checken oder wenn ich mich eine bestimmte Entfernung überhaupt,
Also das könnte könnte durchaus dann funktionieren. Nicht ganz einfach, aber auch nicht unmöglich.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es noch Verbesserungspotential, ne? Sowohl was das Anpreisen dieser App betrifft und man muss sich eben darüber Gedanken machen, inwiefern man äh ja da die Insels äh hochhält, dass,
dass Leute die App auch wirklich in irgendeiner Form als informativ und nützlich empfinden.
Vielleicht nochmal zu lauterbach äh zurück, also in seiner Bundestagsbiografie steht und das ist erstaunlicherweise in der Wikipedia so nicht drin, also wundert mich ein bisschen, ist
also das ist ja okay
Er übersetzt Health Policy and Management in Deutschland Studium der EPD-Miologie und Gesundheitsökonomie in Habert. Ähm
wo er dann promoviert hat auch und war dann achtundneunzig bis zweitausendfünf Direktor des
Instituts für Gesundheitsökonomie und klinische Epidemiologie, IGKE der Universität Köln. So, ja, also hatte jetzt nicht ganz Unrecht mit äh sagen das Herr irgendwie auch
die Miologe äh ist und sozusagen sieben Jahre lang ein Institut, was klinische Epidemiologie im Namen hat
geleitet hat, ja? Also insofern ja.
Wovon er spricht.
Ist der wahrscheinlich der Abgeordnete der potentiell die meiste Ahnung hat.
Äh ähm in dem Zusammenhang.
Ja. Okay, bringen wir das vielleicht mal äh zu Ende.
Chrona waren App äh hat auf jeden Fall noch Verbesserungs äh Potential, aber ich glaube, die Entwickler sind derzeit ganz gut unter Dampf, wenn ich mir anschaue, was äh Apple und Google ihn jetzt auf den Tisch gelegt haben, weil diese ganze Roming-Anpassung und quasi die Existenz anderer Server.
Etwas anders funktionieren
bedeutet, dass da eben Protokolländerungen vorgenommen werden müssen und dass sie im Prinzip dann dualen Weg fahren müssen. Zumindest, was eben diese Verification Geschichte betrifft, weil das funktioniert definitiv anders.
Und also nicht fundamental, viel anders, aber da gilt es sozusagen was Neues zu implementieren, was mit Zertifikaten zu tun hat, et cetera, das muss natürlich entsprechend eingebaut werden, um eben mittelfristig so eine internationale Kompatibilität herzustellen.
Aber ich finde es super, dass es jetzt äh soweit ist, dass wir über sowas wie eine internationale Kompatibilität überhaupt ähm reden können, weil.
Dadurch, dass das jetzt eben vollständig im System ist und niemand mehr gezwungen ist, eine App zu programmieren. Also man kann das ja immer noch tun und sie unterscheiden pro Region im
gibt's hier eine App, dann App und wenn nicht, dann mache ich dir die App einfach selbst. Ja, bei Google halt in Form einer konkreten, generierten App
äh bei Apple ist es dann einfach vollständig irgendwie in den Settings äh untergebracht, wie das dann genau aussieht, weiß ich noch nicht. Das gibt's ja derzeit sozusagen auch noch nicht, aber das werden wir vielleicht demnächst mal sehen und das ist natürlich auch so eine Antwort auf
dieses irgendwie ja, sollen wir jetzt eine App pur mir oder nicht, ist ja alles so anstrengend, wir sollen das machen, das kostet ja nur Geld. Jetzt hat Apple das quasi äh mit Google zusammen für alle.
Erledigt.
Ja? Man könnte jetzt sagen, faktisch äh kommen jetzt die Handys demnächst mit Korona Warnapp vorinstalliert.
So könnte man das äh sagen, genau.
Äh Frage ist, ob die die folgmäßig aktiv ist oder nicht, wahrscheinlich nicht, nehme ich an, aber.
Nein, sie ist die vollmäßig nicht aktiv. Also dieser Optin, das haben sie beibehalten. Es ist halt nur so, dass du eben jetzt, wenn du in einer Region bist, die das noch nicht hat, aber die solche Server hat, dann kannst du es eben einschalten ohne irgendwie so eine App runterzuladen.
Das halte ich alles.
Gut Pavel, ich glaube, wir sind so äh am Ende des Geschehens, weil jetzt auch wieder lang genug, war schon klar, wir mussten hier mal einiges ähm aufholen.
Dann haben wir's für heute, oder?
Ich denke, äh wir haben's jetzt äh zusammen und dann freuen wir uns äh natürlich über euer Feedback,
und all äh äh das und natürlich auch eure Korrekturen, falls äh wir wieder Unsinn erzählt haben, aber das würden wir natürlich niemals tun.
Oder? Nein.
Ähm wir bemühen uns nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen äh ja.
Genau. Genau. Und und ihr müsst euch auch alle bei Pavel mal wünschen, dass endlich diese Historie da in diese Webseite reinkommt. Damit ich nicht der Einzige bin, der die ganze Zeit bettet.
Ja, ich habe ich habe ja auch immer so äh schon vor Augen, was mich interessieren will, genau dieses äh also dann mal die Rangliste nochmal zurückzurechnen für
die ganzen, weiß ich nicht, letzten zwei, drei Monate und dann zu gucken, wie denn die Bundesländer auf und ab steigen und die äh Landkreise auf und absteigen und.
Genau, wir wollen, wir wollen da den den Gewinner äh ermitteln. Wer sich am volatilsten verhalten hat und wo sie alle so durchseucht sind.
Das Ganze vielleicht dann noch so mit steigenden äh äh drei D äh Grafen auf der Landkarte, so wo dann jeweils die Landkreise äh je nach je nach Platzierung dann hoch und runter äh ja.
Genau, so eine richtig schöne Datenlandschaft, wo man dann mit dem neuen Flugsimulator so rüberf.
Oder mhm.
Nur so eine Datenwelt und so mit drei D Brille und allem. Genau das.
Vielleicht ja doch was auch eine Etappe, das würde uns wahrscheinlich schon nach vorne bringen. Okay, wir sagen.
Alles klar, tschüss und ja dann verstehen.